[Laughter]
hey it's friday hooray
ran a couple minutes late because i
forgot it was friday
i told you half an hour before the show
was started this is why i always tell
him like ahead of time because otherwise
he acts like oh [ __ ] i only have like
five minutes so i told him like half an
hour before he's like i still got half
an hour yeah well the thing is i thought
it was i thought it was a thursday i
forgot it was friday we don't even
stream on thursday night so i don't even
know what the hell you thought yesterday
was thursday i thought it was
i thought it was like a uh just a little
short show
oh
so you thought maybe it was like two
years yeah i mean i didn't want to wear
shorts and [ __ ] on for a long show
i could do that [ __ ] for uh uh
about an hour so i don't want to wear
that [ __ ] all night
not on a friday
not on a big show not on a big show yeah
what you doing poke
what you got she's very very mad because
looking at the mice i won't brush her
yeah
like i said she's gotten to the point
now where i can't even walk over in that
direction she's like brush brush and she
like runs over there and jumps onto the
sink and looks at the brush and then
yeah and i went over there and i told
and i was like petner i'm like i can't i
don't have time right now and she looked
at me with these big huge eyes like that
like
no way like her eyes were like all fake
and i felt like so bad
so she's bad she's like going around
like tearing [ __ ] up
all right uh
camp guy says uh cat chat and cocktails
oh cool art wonder if jenny did it no i
didn't i found it on uh pixabay actually
i really liked it as well i always kind
of look for
because i never know what we're going to
talk about on these shows really yeah so
it's really hard to like find a picture
than a cat so i said well we usually
drink on there that's a constant so i
usually try to find something funny to
do with like drinking
and you know we usually talk about
pookie and stuff too so
i try to find stuff with like cats and
booze but there's not really a lot of
artwork with those stupids in it
you know
that's right tax season is over today
today was tax day
so yeah i did my taxes a little while
back
and uh luckily i didn't have to pay
anything because
i didn't make enough
i didn't make enough to worry about it
no
that's good
pandemic's been hit yeah
yeah wasn't like that before that that
[ __ ] well last year i ended up having to
pay
500 something
um yeah but yeah this year i didn't pay
i didn't make that much less this year
but okay it's just it was enough to
worry about it was enough that i didn't
have to which was nice because i was
afraid because i was like oh [ __ ] yeah
what if i have to pay five hundred
dollars it's like i'm gonna be in big
trouble but yeah zach sent us some money
oh yeah
thank you zach
um
zack says i see tom's shirt and keep
remembering what a pain it is for me to
get shirts because i'm both fat at the
moment and have a linebacker's shoulders
i don't know what to tell you oh
speaking of money i wanted to give a
shout out to miguel
who is my friend on facebook and he sent
me a
paypal donation today so that was very
nice so miguel okay thank you so he's
done that a few times in the past so i
wanted to give him a shout out if he's
listening which hopefully he is
so
okay so you want to hear something funny
like
like 15 minutes before the show started
and i'm here at my laptop and it had to
do some like uh updates or whatever so i
was like restarting it and i looked down
underneath the desk
and i saw something on the floor it's
kind of dark under there
i saw something on the floor
and i was like holy [ __ ] i think that
looks like a big huge dried up turd
and i was like did pookie poop in here
it's like she's never done that she's
never pooped outside
the no well okay you just let me finish
the story so i'm sitting there like
looking at it and i'm like i don't i
really don't want to touch it because
what if it is a turd or it's like
because i couldn't tell what it was and
i'm like is it food that i dropped it's
like that you know it's big
and so finally
finally i realized what it was
this is what it was it was
these
severed heads oh
except it was upside down so all i saw
it was like that so it looked like a
turret it's from this from the yeah this
is my um this is my
headless horseman
figure
and he has these little severed heads
that he holds in his hand
you have his he has his christopher
walken head too but i don't know where
it is from the back that does like a
couple little [ __ ] things yeah so it
was like it was laying right like right
down there like underneath the the uh
leg of the desk and i was like oh man
that looks like a big giant turret it
looked it honestly it looked too big to
be a cat turd it looked like a human
turd and i was like well i don't know
how that would have gotten there but um
you know unless i got really drunk one
day
hornets asked me what uh what something
is like
uh
i got my hands on some um
uh designer hrt blends called sus 350
and it's kind of the rage right now
stains
that's what they're talking about oh i
thought you said sus isn't suspicious
sustain 350. yeah it was the one that i
got
and um
it's good um i i injected a full dose of
that [ __ ] today
because the day was the yeah so who
knows what you're getting i wanted to
see how hard it was already did first of
all you uh
uh after a few minutes you uh kind of
comes become kind of short a little bit
[ __ ] short tempered a little bit like
i don't want to hear this [ __ ] that
would stop you know you're like that so
like me all the time yeah
get them away you're like like me all
the time
you start getting hot and you start
sweating out some of that grease just
like you went on on when you first
started hrt it's like that
and um then it just kind of
kind of runs like that it kind of feels
a little bit like deanna ball
yeah
i don't know if it feels like it doesn't
sound like any fun though yeah it's good
it's good
it's good i know it's not a recreational
thing you know what i mean it's a
it's a hormone replacement therapy well
i know that but it's like it still
sounds like here i'm gonna take this
thing that makes me feel like crap or no
well you don't feel like crap you just
you get a little bit aggressive at first
but then it kind of mellows out um well
and feeling hot all the time that's
feeling like crazy not all because i
hate feeling hot it's not all the time
it kind of comes and goes
if you know like the first day you're a
little bit hot and then it kind of
trails off but i'm actually i haven't
lifted on it yet see that's the acid
test if you can lift a lot of weights on
it and have a good workout on it then
you're like oh okay yeah yeah yeah and
then you wake up the next day and you're
[ __ ] all healed up you're like yeah
that's good whoa
yeah
yeah well you know i'm just saying
joints feel real wet i don't feel any
kind of bloating around the waist or
anything i don't feel like uh
um i don't feel like i'm filled with
[ __ ] i haven't had any kind of uh
bloating reaction to it yet let's see
that
if i feel bloated tomorrow yeah i don't
know what it is
normally i wouldn't have taken a full
dose it would have taken the full 350 i
would have broken it up into maybe two
or three injections over the week so
there's no minimizing disturbance but
you know he wanted to know what's it
like it says okay so i just [ __ ] dove
right into it just like you know that's
what a doctor would tell you once a week
you know it's a lot better to do like
once every three to do it like every two
and a half three days smaller amounts
just you know what i mean so there's no
disturbances that's actually a better
way of doing it but doctors just they
just oh once a week yeah well they don't
want to get sued in case something bad
happens so they're like airing on the
side of caution most no actually it's
more cautious to to
take that 350 um milligrams of it and
break it up in three doses over the week
you know you know what i mean instead of
just one big one and then dealing with
it
break it into three pieces and do it
slowly over over
over the week and it's a lot easier on
you
but you know
guys on hrt want to know what it feels
like
you know like a full wallop of it
because a lot of it [ __ ] at once you
know be honest it feels good it feels
real good
um but you know that's not what it's for
but everybody wants to know he wanted to
know like i said i hate feeling hot all
the time that was one of the worst
things and honestly
um i was actually really lucky like when
i went through menopause because i
didn't really have that many symptoms
but i did have the occasional hot flash
and they suck yeah you don't feel hot
all the time i mean i honestly i hate
being hot at any time i would rather be
cold
always i would rather be a little bit
too cold than a little bit too i hate
being hot i hate being sweaty
um i hate it yeah so i hate like any
kind of like humidity it makes me really
really uncomfortable yeah so kind of
sticky and oily right now yeah see i i
love that see that would drive me
[ __ ] like up the wall i love it i
hate it yeah seriously i'm just like
well and we live in florida too where
it's like super humid it's like every
morning i get out of the shower and like
cover myself with baby powder i can't
[ __ ] stand it i can't stand being
damp
i hate it and i hate being hot
it keeps me awake at night and it's like
it's not really that hot in this house
in fact this office for whatever reason
i don't really know if it's just because
i keep it dark in here because i don't
like sunlight but
this office is so cold usually that i
need a jacket most of the time which is
fine with me
but the bedroom is sometimes comfortable
and sometimes it's too
hot it's like too stuffy there's no
ceiling fan in there which is that's one
thing um but so a lot of times like i'll
wake up and it's like i can't ever sleep
with like covers on because it's too
warm in there
you know yeah
yeah
hornet i don't i've said there's no
bloating yet typically it would be the
day after the injections when you kind
of feel it then it'll last about a day
and then it goes away when you take a
big wallop like that but like i said if
you break it up into three over the week
it would um be a lot milder the body
doesn't react to it as
as strongly you know
the endocrine system doesn't like
disturbances so it's easier to just kind
of like break it up do some guys will do
tiny injections every day or you can
inject it into fat which will go in real
slowly
um somebody's asking me uh tom what do
you think about what now
what was it
said tom what are your thoughts on pws i
don't know what that is i don't know
what pws is you have to clarify
zack says uh oh good i thought jenny was
gonna say it was a giant wolf spider or
something meaning the thing that i saw
under the desk
yeah um
it's okay it was just like a plastic
thing well it's like as soon as i looked
at it because for sure i was sitting
there going that's got to be a turd it
looks exactly like a turd
and i thought one of the cats had pooped
and then i was just kind of like oh wait
oh and then i figured out what it was i
don't know why that just reminded me of
something but
here's something that happened when
i was a kid
my mom and she told me this story
because i was sleeping at the time
my mom gets up in the middle of the
night
to go and get like a drink out of the
refrigerator or something like that
and she
just about [ __ ] a brick because she saw
a glowing thing
standing in our living room like by the
sliding glass door
and she was like freaking out like oh my
god it's a [ __ ] ghost it's like
standing in the house right
and then she figured out like she's like
wigging out and then she figured out you
know what it was it was a
glow-in-the-dark frisbee that we had
left on the [ __ ] floor and i guess
like the sunlight from the day had come
in and like kind of soaked in and she
had not noticed that it was there so
then she got up in the middle of the
night it was like glowing like that and
she thought it was a [ __ ] ghost
in the house but i don't know why it was
just shining up on something else or
yeah it was well it was like really
bright she said it was really bright
like green you know what i mean like
that because i see a disc on the ground
no because it was the light was so
bright because the moon was coming right
in like hitting it and it was just like
this big green glow and she you know she
wasn't expecting to see that she just
like comes around the corner and she's
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] there's like a
ghost standing there
that she was like oh it's a [ __ ] glow
in the dark frisbee i don't know why i
remember that that happened like so many
years ago but i just remember her
telling me that me laughing laughing
because she's like i felt like such an
idiot because i thought the [ __ ]
house was honored
yeah i don't know why i thought of that
why i guess because i thought that was a
turd and then it just turned out to be
like a toy you know what i mean yeah
camp guy said i just took some uh
turmeric i wonder if it really handles
muscular soreness like i've heard no
yeah like a lot of people say about the
lake i'm not against like eating it's
not gonna hurt you and it's good it's
delicious yeah it's just spice but um
you know i don't know how much
uh you know health
yeah thing it has turmeric is very um
common spice in india they use it to
make things yellow basically it has some
flavor but not but it's a very mild
flavor
they don't sell a lot of it in the
united states and western cooking
doesn't use a lot of turmeric
so merchants have that [ __ ] around all
the time and they have to come up with
creative ways to sell to rick
all right yeah because not enough people
cook indian food at home so so what they
would do is they said well you know
cures cancer or it prevents cancer
and we'll see that's it yeah you know
that it was what india doesn't have that
much cancer per capita so it must be the
turmeric we'll see the thing about it
there well okay the thing about health
supplements
um particularly any kind of supplements
that are based on like spicer stuff
that's like i said it's not gonna hurt
you necessarily unless you like [ __ ]
eat gallons of the [ __ ] which you
shouldn't do that with anything
but
because it's not a drug it doesn't
necessarily have to go through the fda
so
you can get away with saying some things
about it
but you have to word it in a real
particular way because look i've done
i'm not naming any names but i've done
some packaging
for
different kinds of uh things like that
and
they are very very careful about the
wording that they use because
his company she's working
so it's like if you um
you know if you say a particular thing
like it can do this and that then you
can get sued because it doesn't do that
but if you just say
you can use words like it promotes this
or something like that yeah you can like
say like implication where it sounds
like it does something cool but you
can't like come out and say yeah it
absolutely does this because it doesn't
and you'll get sued
yeah but like i said it's not
the shit's not gonna hurt you usually
um you know it's just that i think
people have an over inflated sense of
how much help it will be yeah that's all
but they
they know that so that's why they use
like all of those kind of like weasel
words yeah
but uh no no it's so sorry to burst your
bubble no turmeric is a delicious spice
very very good cook some indian food
with it yeah in indian food
uh
curry real good [ __ ] sock paneer
[ __ ] uh uh mutter paneer all kinds of
[ __ ] i love soccer yeah yeah all kinds
of [ __ ] you could use i love anything
with paneer yeah
i don't know why there's just something
real there's something just it's very
very mild the cheese but it's i like
just the the whole like gestalt of like
the flavor and the
and the texture of it it's almost like
tofu so well
it's not as soft as tofu it's a little
bit firmer yeah but turmeric is good in
soups jenny uh one of those companies
that she worked for healing butterfly
healing butterfly that's the name of it
they had a tumeric type matcha wasn't it
it well it didn't happen it was it
wasn't matcha but it was like a turmeric
like tea or like a drink tea and it was
delicious yeah it was salty oh it was
it tasted like an indian it almost
tasted like an indian soup yeah yeah man
that [ __ ] they called a tea to get away
with it that's what we said well i don't
even know if they called it tea but it
was a tea like so you drank it like tea
we got a lot of it here still
yeah if that [ __ ] was delicious the
packaging was solid it was like mre
packaging you keep forever so i'm like
man that's good survival [ __ ] there
yeah it was
it was good but i could make that i have
lots of turmeric so really what made it
special to me was the packaging
you know it had real convenient pretty
packaging strong stuff pretty because
flat metallic packet
flat metallic paint i mean i made the
label i didn't made that actually right
yeah it was just like in the gold like
mre bag but i did the label that was on
it are these flat metallic bags kind of
like an mre bag
thank you zack tea or coffee and why
either but i prefer coffee
um
teas are good but i don't usually i mean
we have some of it around the house but
every now and then like we'll be like oh
man let's make some chai
but
usually it's coffee i have it you know
what it's like we have the coffee pot
downstairs that makes eight cups or 12
cups or whatever and i have a coffee pot
right over there that makes one cup at a
time
yeah and so i have like all different
kind of coffee under there all different
kind of creamers i got snickers creamer
we got caramel creamer and i also have
hot chocolate under there too so every
now and then i make some hot chocolate
too talking about those indian spices uh
the best place to get those are places
like house of spices or some kind of
like an indian or or pakistani like an
asian market asian style it's way
cheaper much better you can get
you can get a [ __ ] a huge
packet of turmeric
uh there for
probably five or six bucks it would
probably cost you 30 bucks to buy that
yes because if you buy them at the
grocery store i mean the spices
particularly ones that people don't use
a lot
are super expensive like they'll charge
you like you know six seven bucks for
one that that size whereas if you go to
the asian market you can get like a big
bag of the shoe huge bag for like six
seven bucks and not just turmeric all of
their spices all of them
cumin seeds
um
coriander coriander coriander seeds yeah
uh cardamom pods there's a cardamom
powder yeah there's a spice mix called
garam masala which is the basis for
other
dishes that they use and other others
like a basis for spicy gravies and
so each garam masala is slightly
different
you can make your own garam masala but a
lot of people would just
just buy a packet of pre-mixed garam
masala and you could tweak that just
slightly and make it curry on that or
just run garam masala if you like that
flavor whatever spice mix they give you
but you know you just getting a huge
[ __ ] three pound [ __ ] or five
pound bags of it
for like seven bucks
yeah it's a really really good deal like
way cheaper yeah
you'll be sick of that [ __ ] before you
use it
[Laughter]
yeah we buy like the [ __ ] oracle says
ask about caraway that's do they have
caraway seeds there they don't use
carrots that's what i'm saying i don't
think yeah i think caraway is more like
a western i mean honestly the really the
only thing that you see caraway seeds
used in any great extent is kind of like
sausages or meatballs that kind of stuff
and
they might have it there but
we don't use a lot of caraway seeds we
put them in meatballs but that's about
it see i i save jars and the lids i'll
[ __ ] wash them and repurpose them
even like and it's b and even like
glass
uh maple syrup jugs i'll even save those
and i'll de-badge them clean them
because
when you buy those bags of spices and
[ __ ] like [ __ ] mustard seeds when you
buy them at the asian markets
you can't keep it in that plastic bag
it'll be everywhere yeah it's like a one
use open bag and it's like five pounds
of that [ __ ]
so you've got to pour it in these jars
and then you know have jenny jenny make
me a label
jars so i got all these glass jars with
lids with spices in them you know we
have some one of my hands you guys is a
spice as a jar about that tall and that
big around looks like a barrel and it
just says mustard seeds and it's just
filled with [ __ ] black mustard seeds
you never know when you need them
they keep forever
you know but they're crucial to some
indian and pakistani types i mean any
spice you need
i'm pretty sure we've got got it in here
somewhere and i'm sure we've got like a
lot of it yeah
i got [ __ ] big old bay leaves indian
bay leaves they're like that big [ __ ]
big old cinnamon sticks you can ground
cinnamon
uh flat crushed cinnamon from india
and everything can be
ground down into a powder you know
or sometimes they're just fried in
butter
to release the uh the see that release
the flavor from the big pieces
and then you throw the
you throw the pieces away and now the
butter's flavored and you use that you
know
fry
you fry up [ __ ] basically wet but raw
basmati rice in it real quick toast the
outside of the rice and then pour the
water in it cover it when that rice
comes out to be brown and aromatic and
beautiful with some bay leaves sitting
on top of it throw the bay leaf away
just as
beautiful
rice
make you
fat constant battle
it is constant battle all the time like
the delicious food is always the most
fattening why is that not always
but usually usually
camp guy says i love my indian grocery
store amazing that many of the veggies
are way cheaper than the grocery store
yeah you can get it's a lot smaller yeah
but i mean the one we go to in i guess
it's in lake mary right yeah like mary
house is spicy we need to go back there
matter of fact
there's yeah we need to get from there
it's like it's small but they have you
know several aisles of stuff and they
have like a small produce section a
refrigerated section
and they do have a pretty good produce
selection gotta say there's a bunch of
stuff in there that [ __ ] americans
don't know about
they usually in those indian rest those
indian markets to have a thai section
and you have the thai
curry paste section which are like these
tuna cans
you and they'll be green red
uh brown yellow and there's all these
there's like a hot pink one there's a
yellow one there's a green one and
there's a red one they'll sell the same
thing in a western
uh
grocery store but they'll sell for four
times the price and they'll have it in a
little glass journal it'll be like green
curry paste
that's what they'll call it
or red
curry paste and you get a little jar and
they'll charge you eight bucks for that
[ __ ] [ __ ] no man
that's not what that's not what the thai
with what they have in thailand or
indonesia it's at a big
large it's like a small tuna tuna can no
more like a cat food can it's big yeah
it's bigger than that though it's the
size of a tuna can
and that's only three bucks you use the
whole thing for the dish i thought it
was cheaper than that no actually four
bucks three bucks
the yellow one's my favorite that's the
monoman curry masala masaman
whatever that's how you pronounce yeah
and then there's the then there's a p uh
what was that pyongyang or no
man the purple one
wait is it purple or it's hot pink
there's one that's not pink same thing
yeah and it's i forgot what that one's
called that's a good one too
yeah the yellow is my green one the
green one is too hot for me
what you do with those is you throw
those in a
in a pan
of uh with a little bit of hot okay you
open up you open up a can of uh of
coconut milk and you get some of that
coconut paste off the top of that can
you put it in there like butter you let
that melt and then you throw that whole
can of open that
can up a spice paste and you put it in
there and you fry it in that coconut
milk
and get it kind of toasted when it
smells real aromatic you then
throw chicken in there or bamboo shoots
and then the rest of the uh and let that
brown and then you uh throw the rest of
the
rest of the coconut milk in there
and it might be two cans of coconut milk
depending on how much of it you're
making
and depending on what flavor you're
dealing with you're gonna be adding
other things after that but a lot of
times it's just that
uh with the bamboo shoots in it you pour
that over rice so it's [ __ ] beautiful
but sometimes it's other stuff like
you're
might add some peanut butter to it or
you might add see that's lemon juice to
it on certain depending what flavor you
one time
you made well once or twice
you made
something like a curry or a noodle dish
that had the yellow the masaman curry
stuff
and peanut butter yeah and it was over
like kind of like the glass noodles yeah
it was kind of like a safe holy [ __ ]
that was delicious it was good i thought
it was a little too pasty though
too too heavy but you liked it i liked
it i thought it was real heavy i thought
it was fantastic i think it was better
on rice
see i'm oh you know what if i have a
choice between rice and noodles i'm
always going to pick noodles
i like noodles better than rice i like
rice too like in some applications but
it was a [ __ ] that was thousands and
thousands of cats oh i'm sure it was
which is why it was delicious probably
but yeah you'd have to and the and the
thing about it is that it's so good that
it's like i literally i probably could
have just sat there and eat like three
or four bowls of it and i was like i
know i can't do that because that'd be
like four that'd be like all my calories
for the week you know what i'm saying
but it was so so delicious yeah that
yellow curry and all those dry curry
powders are all blends they're all mixes
there isn't a spice called curry
it's it's like
it's a mix it's a mixture
mostly turmeric
well that's garam masala is like that
too it's just that everybody it's that
everybody has their own
uh like a family version yeah so it's
like the same spices it's turmeric you
know and whatever but um they have it in
different like ratios cumin
it's probably things like cumin chili
powder chili powder maybe a little bit
of chili powder oh cardamom cardamon
[ __ ] um
maybe something
i don't know you can look it up you can
look it up garam masala mixes it's just
yeah like i said it's just in different
ratios like depending
but
yeah they got
and it's easy to cook once you start
thinking the way they think and how they
do it
all that [ __ ] is pretty easy
well yeah i kind of feel like um one
thing that when you first started doing
indian food
is that once you get down like a few
techniques
you can make pretty much anything yeah
you find out less is more what they're
giving you in the restaurant is the easy
way you go that way if you try to get
all do some of these fancy recipes they
won't taste like what you're used to
you're like yeah it's good but that's
not that's not what they gave me at the
restaurant well they gave you the
easiest one
most of the time
and that's
because it's the most cost-effective one
and they're actually it tastes good it
tastes better to me
simplicity a lot of times
speaks volumes really
yeah you don't want to like complicate
the show right you want kind of like the
spices and the ingredients that you use
to you want to be able to taste that and
like kind of all
be harmonious together rather than
trying to like throw more [ __ ] in it you
know what i'm saying to make it like
fancier
but
yeah i mean
your
your butter chicken is like famous
everybody loves it
every time we've made it because people
have come over to our house and we've
made that and it's like
i kind of feel like between your butter
chicken and your pizza yeah that's what
everybody if they're coming to our house
make that make that everybody wants to
do that butter chicken yeah that butter
chicken there's a couple different
butter chickens that i do sometimes i'll
just use my own spice mix that's pretty
good a lot of people like that but
actually the one that the one that
they comment mostly about was sham
that shannon
is pretty legit which is like it's not
even indian it's pakistani and it's like
cheap pakistani yeah
but i'll use that spice mix
uh and i do it my my way
and yeah that is good
it does not taste like something from a
high [ __ ] caliber indian restaurant
or
or a high caliber indian hotel in
[ __ ] new delhi you know no it's not
it's not like that
i've seen their recipes their recipes
are kind of
kind of more mildy and tomatoey it's not
like that this has a little bit of a
zing to it
uh and it's
it's just the pakistani version of it
it's good
if you guys want to try it
there's a company called shan s-h-a-n
and just get that butter chicken and box
of butter chicken spice mix
depend and you won't use it all you'll
probably use about a quarter of that box
for one big thing yeah i kind of feel
like well we've tried all different
brands because if you go to the indian
market
there's a bunch of like you know
pre-mixed like spice mixes like in
little boxes
and
they have like three or four different
brands of them yeah for all the
different dishes yeah the high caliber
one was international i think wasn't
that it was national as you know it's
called that was the house but i didn't
like that one as much
it was a little too good but it was a
little too mild
shannon
is shannon's ghetto and it's effective
we had one
damn i don't know why it's like i'm my
throat's tickling
we had one i can't remember it wasn't
national but it was some other brand
because we tried different uh brands i
like the spices see which one was the
best we had one brand of butter chicken
that was way too hot yeah for me because
i can't eat real hot stuff i get like i
don't either because i'll get like
horrible heartburn and it [ __ ] my
stomach up so i can't eat real spicy
stuff
um but shannon
it seems like a really good balance yeah
it's just spicy and it's a little bit
spicy but it's not so spicy that i'm
just kind of like oh my god
crappy dingy looking packaging with the
boxes it looks like it was it looks like
it teleported itself from 1975
to here it's just kind of dingy colors
and terrible photography on it it's just
and inside that little box is a metallic
bag of just spice mix yeah and it's only
like 1.50 for that [ __ ] thing yeah
they're super cheap super cheap
and i pretty much follow the
instructions but not really i still add
the stick of butter to that
they don't even talk about mentioning
they don't even mention putting butter
in [ __ ] butter chicken it's butter on
the back of that [ __ ] thing you got
to put at least one stick of butter in
there yes
that's why they call it that yeah the
back of that box it never really
mentions that that's what makes it good
stick of butter and a bunch of cream
yeah and uh and they it's it takes
forever on the back of that box trying
to explain to you how to make tomato
paste
because there are so many they have they
don't say you don't have it in a can
yeah you have to make your own tomato
paste so that's like what the whole
first half of the recipe is i started
using i was just using tomato paste
all right that was pretty good
and then i would also use
um [ __ ] pureed tomatoes like out of
the can and puree them that was pretty
good too but you know it's [ __ ]
better
ketchup because it's got sugar it's got
sugar
it's already pureed [ __ ] squirt about
a [ __ ] half a cup of ketchup or a cup
of ketchup in that [ __ ]
it's even better no shame and well you
know it gave me that idea watching
indians cook on [ __ ] youtube yeah
they're like [ __ ] a restaurant guy
why didn't he grab a [ __ ] thing of
hunt's ketchup
puree
puree well technically yeah
it's not puree but there's other stuff
in it that's awesome so i went
yeah
yeah parade puree that's not the
classiest about it
it's an ingredient i did that same [ __ ]
and gave to her and i was like oh that's
what they gave us at the restaurant
yeah that's good yeah yeah that's what
they were doing as long as it's good i
don't give a [ __ ] what they put in well
[ __ ] ketchup within reason
you know but
chicken with spices
ketchup
a whole stick of butter and some cream
and it comes out like a spicy
tomato soup but it's kind of thick
with chicken in it chicken breast yeah
it's kind of like orange pour it over
rice yeah and it's kind of a thick
tomato ish tomatoey sweet or
version
has a slight amount of like lemon zest
kind of flavor to it yeah that's what's
that's what's making the difference
they probably put msg in it
yeah that set but it's good though it's
it's good that's okay there's something
about it's kind of slightly lemony
slightly zesty
and butter chicken doesn't have lemon in
it
in the original recipe didn't it's just
now but you know an indian would go well
you know a snotty indian go like that's
not butter chicken but that's good
you know yeah it's still good as long as
it's good this pakistani butter chicken
and like i said
you can't get too
wrapped up in
oh that's not this it's like if it still
tastes good you can do variations on
stuff it's like chili it's okay there
isn't one chili
there's a lot of different chilies every
time you have chili it's a little bit
different depending on who made it
that's right that's right and every
single person that makes it is
technically american texas style chili
doesn't have beans in it yeah it's got
beans in it you're [ __ ] faking the
[ __ ] it's all meat
and and chili is another variation of
curry it's yeah it's essentially the
same thing it has a lot of the same
spices in it just in different ratio
same cooking technique and the same
cooking technique also yeah
not that same spices but in different
ratios and it's all meat
most of the time pork indians wouldn't
eat pork neither were pakistanis or
muslim
but we're talking texas
they eat the swine
but if it was [ __ ] beef they'll do
that too i think texas chili probably
is beef
but i would think most versions i've
seen most had
most versions i've seen of texas chili
was mostly beef although it might have
had beef and pork in it too i've seen
versions like that too i think it's i
think by right as beef
but nowadays
do the amounts of meat you're talking
about would be very expensive for that
to be beef
so pork is a good substitute it's a lot
cheaper i mean pork is good too yeah i
know just gotta get the rice cuts
tenderloin
midwest outlaw wants to know can you
handle your spice though tom oh my god
he loves hot stuff oh yeah
he loves it his favorite thing
when we lived at the old house he used
to specifically ride his motorcycle all
the way
over here to where our new house is to
the mexican grocery store slash
restaurant just to get that little
bottle of that mayan yokateco yeah
that's super super hot like brown hot
sauce yeah
he loves that [ __ ] could be too cool
and somebody sent us like a huge case
yeah somebody sent us a whole case of it
yeah and i still have it
i still have half of that case i didn't
i didn't blow through it
well you blew through half which is
pretty good which is pretty impressive
because that wasn't that long ago two
years ago
he puts hot sauce on everything
everything yeah
no not on everything well almost
everything i mean you don't put on like
pancakes or [ __ ] like that but it's like
i mean there's an opportunity for
[ __ ] hot sauce there's gonna be hot
sauce on it i mean if you make tacos or
you make an omelet or you make something
like that you put hot sauce on it
barbecue pork sandwich i put hot sauce
on it hot sauce you know i can't do that
my my digestive system can't take it
it used to give me a problem till i went
on hrt
hrt there's something about it it wakes
up your entire engine system and i
digest so much better
i don't know business you notice that
you notice that business heartburn goes
away when you go on hrt
i thought it was the hcg which is a
pituitary gland stimulant i was taking
it's not it's testosterone
testo [ __ ] hook you up you digest
anything
hasn't helped me though because i still
can't you know you get very little
though very little it's any help you're
giving me more yeah it just because
honestly like even even tomato sauce
gives me heartburn which really makes me
sad because i [ __ ] love tomatoes and
i love tomato sauce and it's like and
i'll still eat it but
i i know that if i eat something with
tomato sauce on it i'm like well i'm
gonna be like having heartburn the rest
of the day that's just you have to live
with it a female dose of any kind of hrt
or
anything if it's anabolic steroids it's
10 of what a man takes
so a woman by right should be able to
live on if she's post-menopausal we're
not talking about pre-menopausal okay
because
before menopause and women has her
education system is running
she shouldn't need it
after menopause the
woman's
metabolism slows way down the a doctor
will tell you
about 20 milligrams a week of injected
testosterone
is equivalent to like a man injecting
200 which is
you can live on that without any major
side effects little things you can
negotiate not a big deal
the main side effect on a man is that
without
clomid or hcg
you will sterilize yourself temporarily
in other words it acts like um
like woman's birth control
you'll shoot blanks
because your nuts are like well i got
tests i don't need to do make any
so they're just kind of nuts so they
just go to sleep your nuts get small
most of those bodybuilders got little
bitty nuts because they're totally shut
down they've been shut well yeah
everybody knows that that's that's a
whole like cliche at this point yeah
that's [ __ ] shut down like
[ __ ] they don't care
uh you can still have sex it's just that
you're just shooting blanks
well that's probably like a feature not
a bug yeah that's what i'm saying we've
been doing it for years it's called
birth control pills yeah it's the same
thing yeah we've had to [ __ ] with our
hormones for like yeah a long time
don't
cry
um
anyway
i do both though i'll shoot testosterone
but i also take hcg and i'll take cloven
depending on what what's going on small
amounts
just so uh
just so i'm not shooting blanks and i
don't have [ __ ] little tiny pee
[ __ ] little tiny [ __ ] little tiny
nuts that [ __ ] fall up into your body
and [ __ ] i think that [ __ ] would be
weird as [ __ ] i don't want it i don't
want anything
and those drugs are cheap so you know
what i mean they're about the same price
as aspirin so why not why not [ __ ]
take them you know just keep your [ __ ]
shooting
yeah why where was i going with this
[ __ ] i have no idea i never know where
you're going
women hrt
now you can give a woman more than
[ __ ] 20 milligrams all right and it
it is beneficial
the doctors that know a lot about it
don't know really when at the point at
which when it becomes beneficial and
problematic though
because if you start giving a woman 100
milligrams a week she will slowly
transform into a [ __ ] male
it might take a couple of years but
she'll look like a dude and she'll
basically become a dude start thinking
about it dude
i put jenny on 20
which just give her a little bit of mine
and she kind of got a little bit
aggressive
so backing her down to 10 which that's
also within
every woman's different you treat the
patient you know
and not things are not cookie cutter she
does better on 10
10.
and if you see what 10 milligrams look
like it's half a drop
or a drop a week
now the thing with tess is that it
doesn't quite do the same thing in a
woman that it does in a man it does a
lot of the same things
in the metabolism but it doesn't do
everything
men because we went through
a puberty that involves testosterone we
became androgenized towards it so it
takes over and does a lot of the
features of our body
which might have something to do with
digesting digestion is what we're
talking about
could be that in a woman it's not
test that's doing that might be
something like
what's that with presta zone or what
would it
uh
women use some stuff that guys don't
even really use uh i forgot the name of
the hormone
just the way they are
have been androgynized through female
puberty
what's the word prejudice stone
prejudiced i can't pronounce it anymore
i'm too old and i'm drinking too much i
don't know
um
i'm just gonna say i mean i've always
had kind of like digestive problems like
my pretty much my whole entire life
uh my dad does as well so it's just kind
of like maybe this might just be genetic
that's i i kind of feel like it's my dad
had it my uh great grandmother had it my
grandmother might have had it she died
of stomach cancer so
it's
it goes along that line
it's not
too bad
but
i just have to know
to either avoid certain foods
i can't eat a lot in one sitting or i'll
throw up
um
and well i just have to know well if i
want to eat something that i love like
tomatoes tomato sauce not tomatoes by
themselves like if i eat tomatoes in a
salad
that doesn't do anything but like tomato
sauce
um will absolutely give me heartburn
pretty much every time but you know
knowing that i just have to kind of like
you know
know that going in and be like well i'm
just gonna have to be prepared to deal
with it for the rest of the day so
that's just kind of what you gotta deal
with lion x warrior i got to jump off a
bridge please don't do that electricity
prices are off the roof somebody kill me
um yeah where do you live at though yeah
where do you live ours are not ours
isn't too bad actually we're in a best
case scenario though i mean
it's weird because
the electricity in this house
seems like the bill is less than at the
old house and this house is like fifty
percent bigger that's right yeah well
it's the it's insulated better it's less
it's yeah it's insulated better i just
think it's like a lot more energy
efficient the house has also got the
lower floor is cinder blocks which that
helps the upper floor is cinder blocks
too i don't think it is they said the
whole
center block okay they hit yeah that was
one of the things that they talked about
like hurricane safety that's what the
door opens outward and blah blah blah
and we don't have two we don't have two
central systems we don't have one
central system we have two yeah one for
downstairs
they don't work very hard yeah because
in florida that's kind of a big thing
honestly the house where we used to live
which was only one story and was
significantly smaller than this house
um
you know every couple of years in the
summer the air conditioning would crap
out because it couldn't
deal with it
it couldn't deal with it couldn't deal
with keeping the house at a comfortable
temperature when it was like 40
bajillion degrees outside
so
it blew up like a few times not blew up
but we had to have it fixed like a lot
of times and actually like the the
landlords had to have it replaced at
some point did they not yeah when they
live there though now they're so they're
enjoying that new air conditioner
yeah if you if you have
just one central system in a decent
sized house here in florida
especially if it was the
the other one which is a super floridian
type [ __ ] house or it was just all
glass you know so you can enjoy the
[ __ ] look of dagobah and your
neighbors
it didn't really make much sense
yeah i'm not a big fan of like a lot of
windows or glasses like look i don't
want to see the sun yeah i don't want to
see all the [ __ ] walking around
in their yards and [ __ ] right that's why
the whole as soon as we moved into this
house i put up i had the blinds and i
closed them and then i put up curtains
and i closed the curtains and i never
opened them in this house
this neighborhood is a lot more spacious
yeah that's true this is we're sitting
on just shy of one acre and all the
houses here or most of them are sit
they're pretty spaced out all the
two-story houses are like this we have
one-story houses that are here also
they're kind of like the one we left
so
this is this is a pretty nice
neighborhood you can look it up on
youtube it's called black bear reserve
and use this
now the photos of it are old
but yeah there's a photo of our house on
there but that was from a long time ago
because there's like 10 cars in the
parking lot yeah in the in the driveway
and it's like i don't know and the house
doesn't look like that anymore because
we did some landscaping in the front we
painted the front door
so front door is black now put new
shades in the back uh i'm gonna have to
start repainting it's gonna take a long
time especially under the present
economic conditions the show does not
thank you very much zac thank you zach
to be honest the show does not make what
it used to books don't make what they
used to we're not bitching because we
know that everybody's sucking
that's what i'm saying it's like that's
why i never really said that on the show
because i was just kind of like yeah
patriot you know patreon is down
and probably worse than us man you know
graphic my graphic design work is down
i'm still getting some but it's not as
much as i wanted to do
and so you know so every month now it's
kind of like a little more stressful
than it used to be i mean we did spend a
lot of money moving too
by necessity so that kind of like bit
into the [ __ ] so you know i'm a little
more stressed out than i used to be but
like i said everybody
is going through that [ __ ] so
basically all i'm trying to do i'm just
trying to like find more side gigs i'm
trying to find more you know [ __ ] to do
on the side to like make more money you
guys did he say where he where he was
where his energy went up not yet look
you guys
this goes back to when this shift
started what was our last our last
electric bill was 2
0
6. for a house this size on a national
level that's [ __ ] great but we're in
a best case scenario we're in florida
and florida is running like almost
normal
but the stress of the [ __ ] problems
everywhere else the supply chains are
[ __ ] up
you order something it takes forever to
show up sometimes it doesn't show up
it's becoming worse than brazil was in
the [ __ ] 80s where i was i haven't
had that happen though i mean i've been
ordering stuff like [ __ ] i ordered uh
the mummy trilogy on blu-ray yesterday
never showed up and i got it today oh
well from japan from japan i don't order
stuff from overseas uh certain [ __ ]
medical
uh supplies that i ordered from
china
took a month longer than they said they
would take
they did eventually show up
um
go to the stores here
they're artificially making the shelves
look full there's no the shelves look
full
but there is no selection a lot of
stuff's gone
new york prices for uh beef
and meat
with florida incomes beef is [ __ ]
priced out of the market even as sam's
um
some things are priced normally other
things are just priced just out of the
market where i could not go buy that not
for that price
uh certain things even here at dollar
general store never get restocked
like their store brand cookies i bought
them all they never restocked them
um two liters of soda they have other
cookies just not the same not the
carbohydrate not the store that's the
clover valley whatever they're called
and i want the lemon ones and they never
came back
uh the
two liters of soda
the prices were twice what they should
be
selection way down
they didn't have any diet they had a lot
they had a lot of regular yep they had
everything for that but they didn't have
any diet two liters they had diets in
the in the 12 packs or 24 cases they had
that but they didn't have any diet in
the two liters you go to publix their
store brand six packs or they see their
store ban store brand 12 packs
cans
and um two liters
the selection is just not there it's all
regular no diet
very few cans
but the shelves look full it's just that
there's no selection there
this this is all somebody was like well
no big deal
this is [ __ ] america
all right my whole life i've never seen
that ever
not in america i saw that in brazil i
grew up in brazil like that
because brazil was a non-functional
third world [ __ ] country
always on the brink of civil war where
cartels ran brazil
not a braz not the brazilian government
all right
it's a bad feeling
a very bad feeling because i've i've had
a foot in both worlds
i see it now
this is not a problem that can be fixed
not by normal means
and that's all i'm going to say because
i don't want to get in trouble this is a
channel we're trying to make money
i know how this is fixed
eventually it will be fixed
a lot of people aren't going to like it
i know how this goes
just read a history book
we know what this is
they are lying to us
i know they're lying they know that i
know that they are lying yet they still
lie to us
if you believe them
you are a child
this does not happen by accident
i know what this is
you can grasp for [ __ ]
straws and beams of rays of hope
there's only one way to fix this
read a history book
let me make another drink
lars alright says i've heard that
drinking urine is the big new turning
point man tell no it's not no it's not
going to get the go get off my channel
no it's not all right
that's just you know i kind of feel like
that's a urban legend that comes around
every now and then look at these people
drinking pee now i'm not saying that
there aren't some weirdos out there
that'll drink their mp okay i've seen it
i've seen my strange addiction there was
a whole episode about some weird
[ __ ] that drank their mp or
wanted everybody to believe that they
drank their mp and maybe it was just
ginger ale i don't [ __ ] know
because they wanted to get on tv
but
unless you're like a freak no one's
drinking their own urine
i don't think anybody is that well i'm
not gonna say that because there are
some like stupid people out there but
most people are not stupid enough and so
you know
as soon as somebody says hey drink your
mp for health no thanks i'll be
unhealthy
that's fine
uh zach says thank you very much zach i
learned recently that autistic people
are known to suffer lifelong gut
problems i sure as [ __ ] do and no one
knows why
now see this might explain a lot i was
just thinking about this the other day
because this was something that hadn't
really occurred to me until recently
because
autism spectrum disorder
manifests differently in men than it
does in women
so one thing that i was kind of thinking
of i was like i was reading this article
the other day or watching a video or
something like that and they said you
know signs of autism in women and i was
watching that video i'm like holy [ __ ]
they're talking about me
they're talking about me and like i
never thought
of
of that before and i was just kind of
like oh man what if i don't know but
it's not like i have money to go get
diagnosed or nothing like that but
that would explain a lot because i do
have um
like i said it could just be
a genetic thing because uh i think i
mentioned before like my dad had um what
do they call it diverticulitis
diverticulosis whatever they call it uh
that thing where you have like pockets
in your intestines that like stuff gets
caught in
and um and it's always kind of like
giving you digestion problems
and so i've always kind of i don't think
my shit's as bad as his like my you know
uh it's not as bad as his but i just
really have to like watch
what i eat and like the amount of what i
eat if i eat
like
um
and the older i get too it's gotten a
lot worse i can't eat a lot of like
fried food especially i can't eat a lot
of fried food in one sitting
like the last couple times we went to
like red lobster or something like that
progesterone that was what i was
thinking of jenny okay progesterone
might be controlling that
i wouldn't know okay i'll look into it
but i'm just saying that um yeah last
couple times that we went to like red
lobster i tried to even not get fried
food
but there's enough on the menu that's
fried
that
you know i'd eat and i wouldn't even eat
everything they served and i still
wanted and i still like was wanting to
barf afterward because it was just too
much
so
um camp guys given uh advice on uh
getting a hamburger he's got a bunch of
those in his certain kinds of hamburger
you can ask for
i was gonna talk about this earlier but
we get a bunch of hamburger from sam's
big ol rolls of it about 30 a roll
that price is pretty good i'll pick up
like three of those
those and the big old long pork
tenderloins
and chicken thighs on the bone big packs
of those i like thighs better than
breast anyways yeah yeah
those actually the prices are still
pretty good on that wings through the
roof the [ __ ] buffalo made a
worthless piece of chicken [ __ ] worth
gold
wings
go for the thigh all right
so i got a lot of those in the
downstairs freezer but um
oh [ __ ] oh where was it going from uh
what i was gonna say
there's a lot of the supply chain
disruptions
that are happening in the big stores is
almost kind of happening
because corporations are having problems
try to source something local we got all
these local farms over here i got to
start investigating
i mean some people can't it depends on
some people can't depend on where you
live
we're lucky because we kind of live
right in a real rural area and there's
farms all over the place right
but there are farms in most states
outside of uh outside of the cities yeah
so if you're in that environment
try to minimize your
dependency
on corporate sources of food
see if there's somebody locally raising
chickens
making eggs
and raisin rabbits
okay
because we have them here
there may be also some local people
[ __ ] farming fish
and you get a relationship with those
and there's also lots of lots of [ __ ]
farms up here for uh like [ __ ] like
strawberries and fruit if you want
seafood you should probably head over
toward like daytona and stuff like that
because there's like some i know some
places over there i guess they're still
there but like they have their own boats
and [ __ ] like yeah
word on the street
is that the local food producers aren't
having problems
because they're not as dependent on the
supply chains to make the products that
they're selling
chickens don't require much rabbits
don't require much so you got eggs and
chickens and rabbits and there's a good
source of protein
now if you're in some states of the
draconian they might come in and says no
we're gonna shut this [ __ ] down because
because because of the farting all right
we want you to buy the corporate sources
and we'd rather have you starve if
you're in a state like that
vote with your feet get the [ __ ] out of
that state
let that state starve
because eventually
if the [ __ ] starts breaking up which is
that's normal in history
you're going to end up on the wrong side
of the berlin wall once the breakup
happens
so migrate towards a state that you
think is reasonable
is already happening
i've seen this before
oscar says jenny watch x it's still in
theaters i know
i want to see it
we just haven't gone to the theater
maybe we'll go tomorrow maybe i'll go
tomorrow
you don't have to go
well you don't want me to go with you i
mean you can but i thought you'd be like
i don't want to go no
you know what i mean no if you were
going to be that way then i'll tell you
guys
yeah
i mean
it's free entertainment because like i
said we're already paying for that [ __ ]
i mean i got to pay for the gas
obviously but i mean look at the cat
she's fighting that [ __ ] mouse or
just she threw it
did you throw a poke she threw it throw
it yeah but we already paid for the amc
stubs thing and we haven't even gone to
the theater for like a really long time
you didn't remind me i would have gone
today i reminded you a couple days ago
how often i guess like every five
seconds so i love it so i have to come
in
every
you got to go let's go to the movies
right now
i can't remind you every [ __ ] minute
of stuff
jeez
have some agency if you're you're not
like the memento guy where you can only
remember things for like five minutes
come on you're not that bad i was
watching [ __ ] tv i was having fun
here i didn't need to go anywhere
if you want to go go ahead and go well i
can't go today i couldn't go today
because i got like a bunch of uh graphic
design [ __ ] like piles what is x about
it's a horror movie okay
it's the same guy that did uh house of
the devil and in the innkeepers and [ __ ]
like that yeah i don't want to see it
zach says also i think a i still think a
show on autism would fit the show yeah i
keep forgetting i need to write that
down because
why would autism fit the show yeah i
just think that would be an interesting
topic well we did a show about like all
kind of like other mental health issues
and stuff like that i thought that would
be really interesting well i told him i
said i i saw a video the other day about
autism symptoms in women and i was like
oh my god they're talking about me
and i was like that was literally
something that never occurred to me
before and i was like oh
yeah it was the whole thing
uh let's see
i have to kind of have to pee so
probably you should talk about something
what you got there
oh look at you got the mouse in her
mouth oh
what are you doing
my cousin wesley he was uh deaf and he
had autism
uh but
they thought that came from um
when he was
his mom was pregnant with him she uh had
a bad fever
i don't know if they gave her a vaccine
during that but when he came out he was
he was deaf and he was autistic
and then the deaf the deafness didn't
really have anything to do with any
problem
in his ear it was uh kind of like brain
damage
i guess the uh
the area of his brain that controls
hearing
was disorganized
but he also had autism but i think the
autism actually came from the deafness
um
she was out in california at the time
and they were trying to do all kinds of
weird therapies with him you know
[ __ ] sensory deprivation type weird
[ __ ] or i don't know put peanut butter
on and making smell things trying to
awaken his waking his brain up
in these universities using this
experimental treatment because she was
she worked at a university so she could
get him she worked at palomar
observatory too
what's the matter oh i didn't say it in
the book she's mad because she wants
something
i didn't say it in the book but my aunt
lois from mountain poultry guys
also worked with carl sagan
all right
but she
and she said
and my mom agreed
lois said that carl sagan back in the
day
was the sexiest man alive
he was pretty sexy he was the sexiest
man alive
he said carl sagan could just show up
and get laid
he said the women loved him
i could see that he said just something
about his braininess and his
smoothness in his look he was super
suave yeah and that he could sit there
and he could just talk a woman right out
of her pants
[Laughter]
together you and i will go to the stars
[Laughter]
vangelis playing in the background
though my mom was like oh yeah carl's
second time
yeah he was he was pretty hot yeah yeah
he was like
well you know it's i i see i thought
that like that that that was just my
thing because like look at me i'm the
person that thinks spock is hot and also
lurch from the adam's family no so i
thought like i was just being a weirdo
like normal no but
no according to according to lois yeah i
always thought carl sagan was pretty
foxy according to lois he would he would
walk around the university and when he
would show up
he'd talk to women and [ __ ] when he'd
walk away women would swoon behind his
back and [ __ ] and [ __ ] like you know
like they were like they were like they
were falling out you guys
read the demon haunted world it is one
of the best books i've ever read by carl
sagan one of the best books dragons of
eden is good too but um demon haunted
world is kind of like a classic
zack says something i realized is how
society mostly overlooks people like us
yet we're responsible for a lot of the
innovations everyone else takes for
granted what is like us yeah he's
talking about people like on the autism
spectrum
that's the thing it's like
it's kind of sucky because i kind of
feel like it's gotten better i will say
but there is a gap between people who
actually create things
and people who
know how to sell things that's why
there's a whole thing where
you know people that write movies or
come up with the ideas for movies or
books or whatever
you know they're the idea people but
they're never the ones that like sell
them because those are almost like two
different things it's very rare that you
find a person that
is like super super creative or
innovative or something like that and is
also good at like selling it to the
public
those are kind of like two different
talents and they don't usually
co-exist in the same person which is sad
the only only guy
that that did that if he asked me was
close to sagan
was um
the guy who took over for cosmo so
[ __ ] pick wrestler guy uh black guy
[ __ ]
degrasse tyson neal they're gonna grab
it he is also super sexy yeah he had he
has a real good um
character and personality his books are
also great and
the thing with neil degrasse is the
reason why he could reach out
to society at large is that he was
a science guy but he was also a jock
yeah wrestler yep so he had a foot in
both worlds yeah you know like i said
it's rare he knew how to talk uh to both
audiences
so he he could talk to geeks and he
could talk to like men
you know what i mean he was he was a man
man
but
i would say sagan was too
yeah second was too uh
you could you
a man like me could [ __ ]
hang with sagan
drink with sagan and listen to him
[ __ ] tell me about quasars and [ __ ]
and he'd make it sound cool
like you were talking to spock
you know he had that vibe to him but
when you look at that little player
you know
you knew you you i look at [ __ ] okay
as a man
growing up watching cosmos and then i go
back and look at cosmos i looked at it
it's dated but i could still see it in
in sagan oh yeah sega was a player oh
yeah sega was a player
all right you could take segan to vegas
and have a good time
oh he was a dude like that another
scientist that was also a big ladies man
richard feynman richard fine
big time yeah uh also also kind of hot
i'm gonna say he wasn't on tv or nothing
but he was like pretty famous at the
time i've read some of his books
but
yeah so it does happen there is some
overlap i kind of feel like yeah there's
a stereotype that not so much nowadays
but
particularly going to like the 80s and
90s and stuff and movies
you would get the thing that's like oh
it's the geek and they if they're super
smart but they look all [ __ ] up and
they're all like socially awkward and
stuff which
to a small extent that's true but
not always i mean when i was in high
school yeah i was i don't know it's kind
of hard for me to say because i was like
hung out with the smart people but i
also hung out with people that were just
we didn't hang out with like any jocks
or anything like that but
some of the jocks though or the normal
looking people that were sort of jock or
cheerleader adjacent
were just as smart as we were
so and we hung out with some of them as
well so it wasn't like um it wasn't as
clearly delineated as i guess like a lot
of people maybe thought or like as maybe
it was portrayed in the movies because
like i said i knew most of the people i
hung out with were weirdos but
we do like some
kind of more normal people that were
sort of like popular and stuff and they
were just they were cool they were like
really smart they were
you know they went on to do like [ __ ]
you know amazing things and so
it's not really
it's not really true that everybody
that's like super smart is
socially awkward and weird looking
that's absolutely not true
um
starting 78 what about jack uh pallets
somebody said oh john gora says what
about jack palance hot or not
yeah he had some he had a quality he had
equality um
the thing about it though is
i know this is sad this is just me this
is my thing
as many good movies as jack palace was
in and he was in a [ __ ] ton i'm not
saying that
every time i see jack palance
all i can think of
is that terrible terrible
outlaw of gore movie that he was in from
the 80s it was on mystery science
theater and i've seen that episode like
a million times and i watched that one
so many times because it's hilarious
jack balance is in that playing some
kind of
priest king wizard
situation
and the hat that he wears in that
is
ridiculous and i love it
and there's also
is this from the same movie is it this
movie or he was because he was in like a
lot of shitty movies like during the 80s
like a lot of b movies a lot of weird
italian ones [ __ ] like that like italian
ripoffs which outlaw of gore was too i
think that was an italian production
but he was in this one movie where he's
sitting at a table and he gets hit in
the head with what is very clearly a
styrofoam
rock
and i thought well
there it is that's his low point of his
career right there
although i will say that the hat that he
wore in outlaw of gore is a close second
it was like this really tall
i can't even i can't even describe it
it's like this really tell it looked
like a pope hat kind of but it like
many times more ridiculous so
it was just kind of like so every time
so sorry jack pal well i know he's dead
but it's like sorry jack pounce but
as many awesome movies as he was in
that's all i can think of is him from
outlaw of gore he's not hot
being like well i don't know he had a
quality though the uh
okay look before we get off too deep in
this it's still early
i just want to know so i can plan ahead
do you want to go to nutcoff night at
[ __ ] mannequins tonight
probably not tonight i'm broke i got
money
uh
can we go tomorrow we can go tomorrow
tomorrow is new wave type of yeah i like
it we can do that okay
i'm kind of digging i don't i'm guessing
they're gonna do that every saturday now
yeah because like i said i mentioned
last time
that
since independent bar moved or
barbarella rather they moved
and they're doing a soft open
tomorrow night actually eyebar is
at their new place
and then they're going to do a grand
opening but i'm not going to turn this
up no okay
okay just wait till i'm done okay
he never waits till i'm finished i
didn't know if you misunderstood i asked
no okay i i don't misunderstand what you
asked me i love because i would say
mannequins i listen i know you did i
know i know i was explaining to them
so
i bar moved so mannequins who used to do
something on saturday it's just called
what the [ __ ] saturdays which was just
like whatever you could just request
whatever whether it was
punk rock whether it was the bg's
whatever they didn't give a [ __ ] they
would play anything
but since
barbarella moved and they thought well
maybe we can draw in some of the eyebar
barbarella crowd from saturday night so
they said we want to go like in a more
new wave post-punk kind of direction on
saturday so we went last saturday and it
was
awesome
the whole every single song
was good
i don't think he played a single shitty
song like all night
i was like a mate i was i would have
danced to every song but i was like well
i have to like go to the bathroom and
like rest sometimes
you know what i mean yeah they're
talking about how many pennies we're
throwing at carl sagan billions and
billions billions and billions that's a
good problem
yeah that dude i mean yeah
adriana says she loves carl sagan's
voice everybody love who doesn't love
carl sagan
yeah he's a beloved he's a national
treasure adriana
my aunt
worked worked with him i think for him
for a while and knew him well
palomar
observatory in california she knew him
she said he was
the sexiest man of all times
see i could totally see that's what she
said i could totally say that so it's
not just you
sometimes i worry because sometimes i'm
like ooh that dude's sexy and i feel
like i feel like i'm the only person on
earth that thinks that but she said when
he was around
i think she was his secretary for a
while or secretary of a par of a
department that he he ran so her
secretary in a way
um or she or she was his secretary
uh she said that he would show up from
time to time
and
female students who were like [ __ ]
hot
would try to do everything he had star
power they'd do anything to like get up
there and [ __ ] interact with him and
talk to them and ask him questions and
they would [ __ ]
talk and talk and talk but yeah and he's
oh excuse me i have to go you know how
you know how he wasn't
[Laughter]
i'll see you later you ladies later
[Laughter]
he'd leave like that when he turned his
back you sound like sulu just yeah
yeah it was that kind of thing yeah it
was that kind of thing i could see that
i can see that that you're making me
want to watch cosplays you're making me
want to watch cosmos i have to uh
put my eyes through the thing i have to
look through the telescope
i can do some science [ __ ]
[Laughter]
seriously you should read the demon
haunted world it's been amazing it's a
really really good book i have it
somewhere it's on one of the shelves
over there
um
yeah i mean honestly i i don't know like
i think some dudes like underestimate
how much
women not all women obviously because
nothing is universal
but a lot of women find intelligence hot
and a sense of humor hot
yeah and a lot of times if you're smart
enough and funny enough that'll override
physical stuff
well in my experience women women aren't
that physical
they're just not that physical some of
them are
uh but in my experience no they're not
that physical
it's we're looking for other things
we're looking for other things
a lot of it is security and it's
security and status
the higher the guy's status is in
society the more they like him
uh the more he can provide the more they
like him
status has a lot to do with charisma
okay so it's always a charismatic
charismatic guy who has high status yeah
is this a dude that has like a good like
i said you have to have something to
back it up you can't just be fake about
it but you have to have a good
personality you have to be kind of
confident outgoing like [ __ ] here's
the thing that throws a lot of people
off
charisma
is very nebulous
that's true yeah that's very nebulous
there are gangster rappers out there
that have a lot of charisma they can do
very well
in their time
they may not age well
there are all different kinds of dudes
that have high charisma it's difficult
to [ __ ]
predict what women will respond to but
they're out there they're because it's
not one
just like everything else it's a lot
more complicated right i mean you can
say charisma it's one word but
that's what i mean and that's what i'm
saying like women are complicated okay
and it's just kind of like
a a certain
set of aspects in one person yeah will
be really really attractive
and the same set in another person might
not be attractive just because of the
way that it manifests itself right you
know what i'm saying and carl sagan had
a charisma to him
that a certain kind of woman would
respond to but there were other kinds of
women that would never respond to carl
sagan they wouldn't even know who carl
sagan was
i don't want to be friends with those
girls well they might be good girls just
they might be
a different culture or you know what i
mean they're different you know a
different time and they don't know who
carl sagan was it was
carl sagan every man and every woman
everybody is a person of their place in
time that's true okay
carl sagan in his place in time was the
[ __ ]
yeah there wasn't anybody else like that
in that segment
so
and even though i mean neil degrasse
tyson is similar that's closest too
that's the closest to it he has his own
thing going on he's not just another
carl sagan he has his own thing going on
but
tyson's bigger more physical
more jock do you know what i love about
see and this is what i
how i'm going back to like um some
personality traits that would be like
really unattractive and some people are
attractive in others
neil degrasse tyson one of the things
that i love most about him is that he's
super super picky about movies
very famously he complained about the i
mean just jokingly complained about the
titanic movie that james cameron made
because he said james cameron tried so
hard to make this movie as accurate as
possible like you know the ship and
everything like that and he's like and
yet when the ship sank and they looked
up at the sky
that's not what the stars would have
looked like on that particular date yeah
and it threw him out of the movie and
that made me laugh so hard i'm like that
is
adorable now if anybody else had said
that it would have pissed me off like
shut up but because it was him i was
just kind of like that's [ __ ]
hysterical because he wasn't completely
serious that's kind of like his thing
that he's like super
nitpicky about like
you know things to do with like space in
movies he's always kind of like that's
not right
you know what i mean and that's like i
don't know that just makes me laugh
adriana says that robert plant was
[ __ ] very
charismatic and hot
yeah that was another man of his place
in time
could have done without that hair but
otherwise
in time yeah i know i know i know but
i've never been a fan of that hair he
appeared in a time
where hippie and metal was starting to
emerge he's kind of part hippie part
metal
skinny [ __ ] with the hair he
could sing like a [ __ ]
and he's singing about tolkien and
mystical magical and [ __ ] and my woman
and this and that and i'm dead on the
killing floor and it was a mixture of
[ __ ] blues and
mississippi delta blues missed with
mixed with british mysticism and
tolkien
it was which saying i mean if you sang
about that usually if you didn't look
like that or you didn't get away with
that you couldn't get away with that
because everyone just think dork man you
[ __ ] but in that place and time
with that delivery and that look
yeah robert plant was the [ __ ] that just
goes to show you can pull off the jelly
shirts and the [ __ ] bell bottoms in
those days yeah
yeah
yeah
i mean
[ __ ] a lot of stuff has to do with
confidence yes yeah and confidence text
confidence and context yeah and
confidence is not really something you
can fake
you have to be a person that i am
completely comfortable
in myself whatever it is that i'm
wearing even if it's ridiculous or
something like that you have to own it
and you have to absolutely believe with
every fiber of your being that you own
that well there and that will come
across a dream they're not living the
dream there that will come across
if you try to do it and you don't have
the complete
like you're a little bit insecure or
something like that it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work out you gotta
[ __ ] you gotta commit
gotta commit well at the time that
you're seeing all these uh recorded
films of uh
led zeppelin doing their thing
they were at the top of their game
they were they were basically rock gods
as long as they stayed in character and
did their thing and put on a good show
no one was going to really question what
they did
they were
kind of like like pink floyd
just didn't question pink floyd if it's
on a pink floyd album then shut the [ __ ]
up if it's on a pink floyd album just
shut the [ __ ] up pretty much on a pink
floyd album look
they were [ __ ] masters of their genre
you do not question dark side of the
moon it's like a microphone it's like a
mic drop and they're just like right
it's you're welcome if you're on a pink
floyd album you have no
authority
to say anything about it
because and [ __ ] roger waters and
gilmore and shitty they were musical
geniuses they
they were
very
very very good
very good
you just had to accept it
these are british dudes at the top of
their game at the right place at the
right time and um no you didn't question
that [ __ ]
um to this day young people can listen
to the dark side of the moon and they
realize that something very special very
special real good and i'm a goth dude
that wasn't i listened to that [ __ ]
because it was awesome a lot of people
listened to that they knew exactly what
they were listening to a lot of guys did
yeah uh
even the punk rockers you know [ __ ]
um
uh john lyden he couldn't stand allen
parsons project and prog rock and
[ __ ] pink floyd i get it not because
they sucked it's because they couldn't
do that
they knew that and he said that he said
yeah they were awesome but that [ __ ] was
musical perfection [ __ ] that that's not
the world we came from
they were ghetto hood all right
counsel the states they didn't have that
kind of musical education so they came
at music a different way
which is fine both ways are legit right
i like both things
styles yeah now america had that too
but when it came to the united states it
would have been donald fagan
all right donald fagan was from uh
steely dan and then he went solo
that was our version of pink floyd
musical perfectionists
all right steely dan was [ __ ]
great
that's not goth music
her dad listens to stevie dan her dad
listens to you then yeah and i'm old
yeah all right now my dad is even older
yeah
but he's right steely dan is [ __ ]
great man there you go the lyrics are
[ __ ] perfect the [ __ ] i will say
one thing this is really really good
one thing in my about my dad he was into
like a lot of kind of like southern rock
which i was never really it's lucky like
the eagles and leonard skinner and stuff
not that wasn't his favorite but
he got me into a lot of really good [ __ ]
when i was
very small he got me into the beatles
when i was like tiny
and i was just kind of like because i
grew up listening to the beatles and the
doors and [ __ ] like that was always on
in the house
and you know and steely dan stuff like
that that was always on in the house and
it's like i think for a time when i was
a teenager as most teenagers do i was
like kind of rebelling because i got
into like new wave and post punk and
stuff like that tina just showed up all
right what's up team but the cool thing
about my dad was that my dad was kind of
like he liked all his old stuff um
but when the 80s came along
he liked some of the new wave [ __ ] he's
like duran that's good that they're a
good band you know what i mean um you
know so
he wasn't like a verse he might be now i
haven't talked to him a long time but
he was actually like kind of open he did
like a particular kind of music but he
was pretty open like when the 80s came
along uh and i would listen to like new
wave in the car he's like hey this is
good you know what i mean so he wasn't
like an [ __ ] about it yeah
so which i thought was really good and
like i said one of the things that i
think is awesome that one of the best
things about my dad was that
he raised me
him and my mom they raised me in a house
that was like filled with music we
always had the beatles or the doors or
some [ __ ] like that on
and so i grew up with like a lot of
really good music always
always on in the background seems like
everybody in the audience is [ __ ]
agreeing with us
that uh yeah
pink floyd and stevie dan and some of
those prograc bands doesn't matter what
your subculture is and what you normally
listen to those bands were great bands
yeah it's just good including led
zeppelin it's just good they were very
they were just great bands
good music good quality it was authentic
it was authentic they were doing what
they were doing
it wasn't a copy
that's what it was you know well you're
like okay
there are some bands that transcend
genre yeah like i said there are some
bands and i'm not you know [ __ ] on
it there are some bands that like for
example this our subculture if you're a
goth or you're in an industrial there
are some bands that only
people that are into gotham industrial
are going to be into that [ __ ] because
it's very specific
but then there are some kind of bands
that
anybody that's into anything um can
appreciate how even if it's not like
their favorite they can still appreciate
that that's really good [ __ ] yeah you
know what jenny knows she'll walk on me
i'm i
i love reaction videos i'll watch them
all day long and there's
some of the [ __ ] highest rated
reaction videos are young
black people
listening and reacting to old music to
see what they think of it
and
man universally
when they [ __ ]
see pig floyd or they listen to pink
floyd
one one dude was like this is my
favorite van this is the best band of
all time
and and
and he he's like he's a basketball
player and [ __ ] and he's like and he'd
never heard pink floyd never heard of
pink floyd and [ __ ] he started going
into more pink floyd
certain tracks off a dark side of the
moon
certain tracks off the animals album
and he's like this is [ __ ] awesome
they don't make anything like this
anymore it's like this is
and
and he's like oh
oh yeah oh i see what they did
it's just
pink floyd was its own thing and they
were just musical geniuses and they knew
how to write music and they knew music
theory and they just
knew how to [ __ ] with your emotions
and they knew how to put on a show in
that
in that genre you know
people recognize it when they see it
and they also like stevie dan
because it has a very it's like just
like cam guy says it was very very
smooth
and the lyrics were real gangster
all about being the loser
having everything and losing it
you you suck it's you suck lyrics you
suck but you know what
it's awesome that you suck
it should suck
you know that that's doing it yeah right
life sucks but it that's that's the
romance of it
you can't win forever that's the [ __ ]
that that that's steely dan vibe you
know
and pretty much everybody can relate
everybody no matter what generation
right yeah you had everything but you
better get vegas and you lost it all did
you [ __ ] suck
but that's the game see that's the game
i kind of feel like maybe
i kind of feel like maybe
this is why
[ __ ] like 80s new wave is still like
pretty popular
um even among like younger people and
stuff like that because it's the same
kind of yeah it's well it's coming from
a place of it's not fronting it's being
true they're being honest they're being
uh earnest right
and i think the thing well
the thing that happened and i think this
started to happen about the 90s yeah if
i remember correctly because i was
around back then and i and i was you
know in my 20s so i remember this
happening
i remember there was some time in the
90s where
everything went
culturally we went to a place where well
we're just going to
everything became like meta and like a
joke and so everything kind of became
frontend or joke or like you know what i
mean everything was like a joke
it wasn't cool to have like genuine
emotions or to express genuine emotions
or to be like earnest if you did that
then it was like funny right you know
what i mean so i kind of feel like a lot
of people
are responding to
the actual even though
from our point of view it might seem
like cheesy and sometimes it is
depending on who we're talking about
but in the 80s
a lot of that new wave music and stuff
like that they were being very earnest
they were being very honest about their
emotions and i think people are
picking up on that yeah it's not glib
it's not kind of like oh yeah i feel
like oh i'm such a loser oh i'm feeling
like that and it's like self-aware
and i kind of feel like that whole
self-awareness thing that came about in
the 1990s
was a little bit detrimental it made
everything it put everything like it one
removed like we're we're this far from
our emotions we're not gonna like feel
any emotions we're just gonna like
pretend and then we're just gonna like
laugh about it so i kind of feel like
it's
it's like a fake version of that so i
think that's why a lot of people still
respond to stuff from before that time
now tia jumps in goes yeah black people
love old rock music just like me i love
it let me tell you jenny i know you i
know
i tell you to i know you're not as old
as we are
you know
but i remember what it was like
back in the day
black dudes were very ethnocentric about
what music they would listen to
they wouldn't listen to white music
okay they'd listen to black music
but white dudes listen to both
we listen to white music and black music
yeah if the black music was good
i mean most yeah everybody i knew did
yeah that's why you got all this black
dudes going man they stole this from us
when we we were listening to it
we didn't steal it we listened i mean we
didn't kind of steal it but but no it's
just
it's just called influence yeah because
we were listening to it and it was
evolving forward yeah you know because
we were listening but
a lot of it had to do with the social
constructs of the time and access
black dudes and black girls couldn't
break out of the bubble because there
was no internet back then
they were gonna go to a concert a metal
concert or go down a [ __ ] store and
buy a metal album they didn't even know
what that was or a rock album
they might hear something on the radio
but they had to hide it from their
friends that they were listening to that
[ __ ]
now that you have the internet everybody
can see everybody else's stuff and you
got black people and black dudes going
into the past and making videos and
listening to [ __ ] out of the past oh
[ __ ] it was great
which is great because it's all
one big fur ball now
everybody knows well you know what's
weird it's like do you remember it was
access do you remember the big deal they
made in the late 80s and early 90s about
every time you'd have like a black
punk band like bad brains yeah or
living color yeah or fish bone fish bone
or something like that where it was like
a crossover everybody liked a big huge
deal about it
bad brains was a big huge [ __ ] deal
because it was new yeah it was new yeah
but it was also happening in rock where
where run dmc and aerosmith doing a song
together i remember that being
a huge [ __ ] deal when that happened
that was like a huge [ __ ] process and
rock rock and rap were blending like
beastie boys
which is a blend of them both
so it's always been happening it's just
happening faster now and now there's no
restrictions
you don't have merchants in the way of
the access if you understand
so everybody can now see what everybody
else is doing even in the past and why
people didn't know and this and that you
see i knew
when i was back in the 80s
a young goth coming up
listening to bauhaus
and sisters of mercy and skinny puppy i
was also listening to public enemy
because at that time public enemy and
skinny puppy
sounded kind of alike it was kind of
like industrial
with all the [ __ ] scratching and you
would be surprised how many like
white ass industrial people were
listening right public enemy and [ __ ]
like that
that goes back because they didn't
really see a difference between those
two things black people didn't know
about it but white people knew about it
blackvue didn't know the crossover but
we did
at the time when american punk rock of
the ramones
and the [ __ ] and the ramones
and blondie in old new york back when it
was a ghetto
they were also listening to early rap
music
malcolm mclaren was there and ranked
buffalo girls and reggae they were super
into reagan yeah well they have five the
brits were
so even early punk rock american punk
rock of the [ __ ] early 80s was
already cross-breeding with [ __ ] rap
in new york in the 70s
okay and
because it was all people didn't know it
was all outsider music it was outside of
music right so they didn't really see a
distinction they're like well this is
our genre that's nobody thought like
that back then i don't really remember
things going into
really discreet categories until later
right
i mean i kind of feel like when i was
young like in the early like late 70s
early 80s
everyone that was into like weird [ __ ]
or like outsider music no matter what it
was
kind of hung out together nobody really
like thought about it you like weird
[ __ ] i like weird [ __ ] right that was
like when i was living when i was living
in detroit
in the
in 87 and 88 89
coming up in the early goth clubs which
was like this we're talking about the
crow era
all right the shelter
saint andrews hall
city club
the [ __ ] that was happening around that
you had skinny puppy front 242 with
these are the industrial bands all right
but you also had a house
and a house was a mixture of industrial
and rap and r b
house became techno
people think techno came from europe no
it came from detroit that was white djs
and black djs spinning in the same clubs
doing a fusion
back in detroit
around 87 88 89
right before i went to the army
i was there
let's go the restroom
yeah i mean like i said it's always been
even going back to the old days like a
lot of new wave from the late 70s early
80s particularly coming from britain was
influenced by reggae because a lot of
young white
british kids
were listening to reggae
and were incorporating it into their
stuff that's where the whole subgenre of
scar came from that was like sort of
like a punk reggae fusion
and even goth bands like bauhaus like
incorporated like some ska stuff into
their you know into their repertoire
into their reggae or incorporated reggae
and their repertoire because a couple of
the members were really into that
so
like i said it wasn't
i don't know i kind of feel like it
wasn't as
compartmentalized back in the old days
like i said it was
you had two things you had like the
mainstream which was one big monolithic
thing and then if you were into
something other than mainstream there
was like all these little bitty things
around the edge and if you were into any
of those things
no matter how different they were then
you kind of gravitated to one another
just because you weren't into
the monolithic mainstream thing so
i think there was like a lot of cross
breeding it doesn't work that way
anymore because now everybody kind of
has their own little niche and they
don't do their own thing but back then
there weren't any of these little niches
really
it was just kind of like
there's the mainstream culture and we
are
not part of that
even though our interests don't align
completely like we are still like
outsiders so we just kind of hang out
together so we our [ __ ] like melts
together so i think maybe that's where
that whole like explosion of creativity
came from around that time i could be
wrong but
i kind of feel like that's how it felt
to me at the time uh growing up
um
tila says did the animals sing house of
the rising sun yes i love that song um
my brother
eric
used to have a punk band who played
around in daytona and orlando deland
many places back in the day
and they used to do a kick-ass cover of
that song it was so so good there's
nothing like listening to the house of
the rising sun in the french quarter
dressed up as a goth kid
walking around in the [ __ ]
in [ __ ] the late 1990s man it was so
[ __ ] funny because it was it was
awesome because that's what they were
talking about
french quarter
there is a house in new orleans
they call a rising sun
yeah
what's funny is that you hear that
dude's voice and you look at that little
dude singing it little look like little
swole
well i have to say my brother's friend
my brother's band uh who did an awesome
version of that song
uh my brother played guitar yeah
and the singer
was this little bitty skinny
dude with glasses his name was auggie
yeah yeah and he sang the [ __ ] out of
that song yeah i saw him do that like so
many times because i used to go see him
there used to be like this little coffee
house in daytona like on the beach side
what was it called up in atom it was
called up in atom for a while like atom
like out of you know
and uh they used to play there all the
time and it's like i used to love every
day everybody [ __ ] went ape [ __ ] when
they played that song yeah they did a
really good since i've heard this on
buffalo girls go around yeah buffalo
girls go around the outside yeah on the
outside dosie dodie apart okay that that
band
was uh managed by i believe malcolm
mclaren or he was involved in that band
and he put that together after he was in
new york and saw basically rap acts they
were doing a bunch of scratching and and
stuff
and this is out in some [ __ ] burned
out [ __ ] place out in the bronx you
know it was like something out of mad
max that was back when new york was poor
all right
and he put that band together and it did
real well malcolm mclaren was the
manager that put together the sex
pistols a punk rock band in
front in england
t if you never heard the sex pistols go
listen to the sex pistols album
never mind the bollocks
where the sex pistols the bollocks the
bollocks yeah that's good holy parrish
of doom says don't let me be
misunderstood i think that's another
animals another song yeah that's
actually also a really awesome song if
you heard that one
okay yeah but he's talking about all
kinds of stuff and then talking about
floyd and janice genesis was great too
genesis was great i was more a fan of
genesis when peter gabriel was in the
[ __ ] because peter gabriel
i kind of feel like because i liked a
lot of his solo [ __ ] too games without
frontiers is still one of my favorite
songs
um he was like a total weirdo and i mean
that in the nicest possible way i kind
of feel like once he left
they went more in like a charty
direction
which i don't hate it
i think i like the genesis stuff from
the 80s where they were very much up in
the charts and on mtv and stuff i like
it more now but at the time i was just
kind of like [ __ ] this it was so it just
seemed too dad music to me yeah but i
like it like land of confusion and all
that kind of stuff but
they were another one that was about
perfection they were the perfection of
pop music at that time and it was like
yuppie pop music
it was like a dude on wall street would
listen there that's what i'm saying i
kind of associated it with like yuppie
rock guppies all right which nobody
liked in the 80s now t comes back and
says i love that [ __ ] buffalo girls
song
okay look
buffalo girls was a [ __ ]
proto-industrial rap song it was a time
when
gothic industrial music and rap were the
same genre
they were the same they split later
it was a
it was just a weird time in history
proto-industrial had a lot of rap in it
and rap had a lot of industrial in it at
that time it was underground music for
people that were
in the underground and rap was
underground it was it was not
i mean now it's like ubiquitous yeah but
no the rap world was not some dude in
the basement would do i mean look
the first real rap album i got my hands
on was yo bum rush the show by
public enemy
and the cover are these [ __ ] black
dudes with berets they're like black
nationalists all right like black
panthers or something they're in the
damn basement with [ __ ] maps
everywhere over their damn [ __ ]
putting their hands together over their
control table you know i don't know what
it was it just look it's like a military
meeting of [ __ ] black nationalist
terrorists that's what it looked like
and
that [ __ ] album was the [ __ ] man go
listen to your bum rush the show it's
real primitive it's like something you
would make in your
basement with equipment that you just
bought
but it's it's genius it's genius and
that's the way skinny puppy's first
stuff sounded like
it was
goths in the basement with equipment
trying to make songs well and it's and
it's not for you
the music is not for you it's for them
you're just watching it see that makes
the best [ __ ] that's what makes it so it
might not makes them it might not make
the most money for those people in but
that's the [ __ ] that's going to be
remembered they're talking about their
friends they're talking about their
friends and what they want you don't
have anything to do with it you're an
observer
and that's where true genius is that's
when that's where genres come from
that's where innovation comes from
and old rap was better much better than
new rap
because the corporations and big
business and money was yeah i kind of
feel like look i
i understand
the you know
i like money you like money
you like money
we all like money
um
but this is a constant struggle because
it's always kind of like you want to
create something
that is true to you yeah um but you also
don't want to starve to death so you
know what so it's really kind of like
this thing but you have to remember that
like
most of the best [ __ ] that's ever been
created was created because that person
just wanted to create and it's like look
this is me
and people still remember it maybe 100
200 years later
maybe they didn't make any money at it
at the time look at [ __ ] poory uh hp
lovecraft or somebody like that who
wrote all these stories and you know he
died without really knowing anybody but
which is sad he didn't make any money at
it even though now like [ __ ] his
shit's in the public domain so
everybody's like making stuff off of it
but
so it's kind of it's a trade-off you
know what i mean and especially like
somebody like me that's like a you know
a writer and it's like i like to
think that maybe yeah
one of my books would but honestly it's
just kind of like i'm always kind of
like well
do i want to write something that's like
popular i don't really know how to do
that or do i want to just like write
something that i want to write because i
kind of feel like [ __ ] that i'm
interested in
no one else is interested in but maybe i
shouldn't worry about that yeah maybe i
should just like just do me and like not
worry about it he said thank god for
reaction channels because it inspires
her to go back and to listen to every
all the old music that her uncles and
her and like her relatives older than me
they are good ideally they're very good
i do like those and i like to record
of what
before i die and our generation dies off
of the fact that when you look at
something like public enemy we're
talking about earlier its success wasn't
from black people it's from white people
because white people bought those albums
and listened to it and you say why why
would they buy that
it was the black nationalism
that got me to listen to it and the
sound
i'm now in another world
listening to this other dude with his
problems but i can relate to his
problems i'm now seeing it from his
point of view
it's funny half the [ __ ] that he says
it's supposed to be funny though but
then it's also i understand his
frustrations
through it
and then like the videos started to come
out which add to it
okay
if it did not have the black nationalist
element
that ban would have failed
and a marketing executive would have
told you no don't put that in there
don't put that in because those
[ __ ] are part of the damn
machine no
make that [ __ ] look black nationalist as
a [ __ ]
because why people will buy it i'm kind
of like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah because it's now it's a show and i
understand that
it it did they it was a [ __ ] it was a
great idea
totally in some ways
this is like a weird thing to say but
things that are very very personal to
you yeah and you're expressing things
that are very personal to you
if you do that without any
worries about oh is this going to
resonate or blah blah just put out what
you feel
and you would be amazed how many people
[ __ ] resonate with that you think
you're alone in the world i'm the only
person that feels like this look at the
[ __ ] smiths for christ's sake yeah
morrissey
um as much as he's like a [ __ ] bag
nowadays
but like back then
yeah um you know he was like this weird
awkward
you know [ __ ] socially isolated kind
of like but everything that he said
it resonated with a whole entire
generation of people and is still
resonating with people yeah so i kind of
feel like don't worry too much about are
people gonna relate to this am i gonna
are people gonna just do just like talk
about your own [ __ ] feelings and you
would be amazed at how universal that
[ __ ] is yeah because you think that
you're the only person that feels that
and that is not the case that is not the
case yeah i mean and you know i mean
[ __ ] i'm listening to [ __ ] chuck d
and [ __ ] flave you know [ __ ] doing
their thing and i understand exactly
what they're talking about and here's
the thing even though
they don't realize i go yeah i'm white i
feel the [ __ ] same way
i feel the same way that's not just you
man that's why we all feel this way
that's what i'm saying but but you're
you're able to
what their offer you is a transportation
to another viewpoint
that you can now see the world from
another viewpoint and you go yeah yeah
yeah it would look that way to you
wouldn't it it would look that way i
feel the same way you know it's just
it's that kind of stuff but see that was
that's in a way that's kind of what was
awesome about
particularly like the underground of
like the 70s and 80s is that we didn't
really have any framework of you know
you know this sub-genre that sub-genre
like i said everybody that was not into
mainstream stuff yeah
you would hang out with that person
because like well you're not in
mainstream stuff like you like weird
movies you like weird music okay let's
hang out together and so you would like
trade tapes and you would do kind of
[ __ ] like that and even if all of their
[ __ ] wasn't exactly to your taste
you would kind of like get another
perspective
on stuff right and
you know and i and i don't know
i don't know like in a lot of ways i
think that now it's a lot better because
you can like find whatever you want you
can find anything from any timeline
but back then you were kind of like
forced to like hang out to force that's
like that a bad word but the medium was
narrowband it was very very narrow band
you had to listen to albums to know what
was happening in the outside world yeah
okay that was our
facebook
or our twitter
we now have twitter and facebook and and
internet and you can now all
talk to each other you got people to try
to stop that but
we all know what the hell is going on if
you're smart
now
adriana says lou reed also seemed to do
song out of isolation
yeah yeah you read was another scene and
he's good that you brought him up that
was the heroine scene a lot of it heroin
and art in new york i love lee reed i
love velvet underground i love that hole
now whenever i love heroin i just love
that whole yeah they were the
proto-goths really of their times oh big
south scene was a lot like that i love
velvet underground yeah the early god
scene was a lot like that but you gotta
understand something he's talking about
old new york never mistake old new york
for the present new york of today
everything is in its certain time and
place
it's always moving around
the the new york that they were talking
about is long gone it's now
very high rent
uh the new york they were talking about
has a greater analog in detroit it was a
lot more like detroit what they're
talking about
so that that's one of the things though
new york's always trying to get [ __ ]
street cred off these old [ __ ]
characters but these old characters were
talking about the detroit that's been
long erased by money
go to the restaurant but i will say that
i mean
new york still got cool [ __ ] going on
i've been there for
several years at this point but i used
to go there pretty much every year uh
for a long time
and i'm a big fan i like new york city i
always really like new york city and
i like the whole vibe of it it's not
like it was back in the old days
but you know
when everyone was like squatting there
and everyone was like getting heroin and
stuff it was like bombed out and [ __ ]
but
there is like there's a romance in that
but um i kind of feel like maybe the
romance is only like in hindsight
perhaps
but
i still like
going there there's still like some
remnants of the culture that still
remains there or at least was like the
last time i went there i think the last
time i went there was
when was it 2000 oh it was a long time
ago 2009 which wasn't seen that long ago
but it was that long ago
but there's still like cool [ __ ] going
on there dj maniac is from there he can
tell you there's still some cool [ __ ]
going on there probably
but um
tila says i found a few older white
people reaction channels and they are
hilarious now see that's probably
something that i would prefer because
honestly
i like the real like tom loves those
reaction channels because every now and
then like i'll go in the bedroom and
he'll be like watching
hey these like 19 year old
kids are like listening to pink floyd
for the first time and their their minds
are blown or whatever but in a lot of
ways
i think it would be funnier
to watch
old people
like lipstick to [ __ ] i don't know why i
just said that would be funnier too nah
every time i oh old people listen to
that music
everything i hear they're like that's
what i'm saying so in a way that'd be
funny because it'd be like all cranky
you could but what i was saying about
new york though is that i'm going to
finish that off okay
the new york the uh that velvet
underground was talking about is the new
york that you see in the movie um
midnight cowboy
that's what i'm saying it's not new
york's been gone a long time
okay new york is still cool i've been
there but
it's not like it was back in the old
days and like i said i'm not sure
that you'd have wanted to live there
back in the old days but it did like
produce a lot of really really cool [ __ ]
in the sense that
sometimes really cool [ __ ] comes out of
adversity
so there was just i don't know it was
just like a whole like vibe it was a
whole time and place so you kind of had
you had the velvet underground you had
bloody and you had like [ __ ] cbgbs
you had the talking hedge you had like
all that kind of [ __ ] going on
um at that time
and
i just i don't think that will ever be
replicated because like i said nowadays
i'm not and i'm not saying that oh thank
you hayden great show
thank you very much that's awesome
i'm not saying that like nowadays is
worse than back then because that's dumb
but
in a lot of ways
as much as i like
nowadays that you can just have access
to anything hayden gave us a 20 super
chat oh my god that's so much money
thank you very much hayden i know that's
amazing did he say does he have a
comment no he just said great show thank
you great job
thank you
but
i mean there's always a trade-off
i like a lot of things about nowadays
because like i said back in the day
it was much harder to have access to
things if i wanted to watch a movie from
the 1970s it was very difficult
i'd go to the video store they don't
have it now what am i gonna do i'm
[ __ ] i can't watch it
and so
the fact that people nowadays are people
that grew up
nowadays and just like uh are used to
just having access to anything
i can watch any movie i want perky
pretty much i can listen any music i
want
like right now
and that's like kind of mind-blowing and
i and i like that
i like being able to like come up my
computer and be like hey i want to watch
this movie from like [ __ ] 1972.
yeah you know look dj let me watch that
and it's just kind of and i can do that
and that's like [ __ ] crazy a while
back dj maniac said [ __ ] public enemies
nation of millions was always an
industrial i mean dude i feel the same
way yeah and utah
maniac is a [ __ ] he's a dj and he's
mixed
and [ __ ] he can attest back in the
day
the difference between in the early
industrial and early rap there was very
little difference
it was
the only difference was the race of
people involved in the subject matter
but the sound
the vibe behind it there was a lot of
crossover
because everyone was experimenting
they were all in the same clubs too yeah
just different knifes nobody had done
that yeah right it was all like new
technology it was all like it was all
like burgeoning yeah which like i said i
don't know if you'd have that like
replicate because back then
um
you know we didn't have the internet we
didn't have yeah you know and a lot of
the uh equipment to do stuff was like
really expensive so
when you had people doing these
experimental things
with
music or film or whatever that was like
the first time that that had been done
i mean nowadays you do something like
that everybody's like seen it
because everything's been done i feel
like
we might have gotten to a point in
history where every single thing has
been done yeah i mean i don't want to
say that that's probably not true but
it does seem like everything's been done
the technology allows you to do anything
you can think of which is good yeah but
there's also kind of like a dark side to
that too there's also a lot at once
yeah
and that's the thing you can't yeah and
you can't and everybody can't
i mean back then it was kind of like we
didn't have the internet so it was kind
of like you had like i said you had
mainstream culture and then you had
underground culture
and
everybody kind of knew like when the
weird movie came out everybody saw that
when the weird album came out everybody
heard that yeah so you know what i mean
nowadays that would never happen today
because there's so much stuff today i
was looking at my tablet i was watching
a video and it went on youtube it went
to a commercial
and it now gives me music videos which i
like that i'll listen to a music video
so they'll they'll they now give me
music of the videos
and i don't know what band this was it
was a japanese girl
i think the name of the band was omg or
the song was omg because she was saying
oh my god it was and it was a mixture of
japanese and english
and she was dressed funny as [ __ ] and it
was just like this crazy
and i watched those and it was it was
creative
it's a japanese girl singing a song
called omg
and i don't know why they suggested it
it just came out as a commercial
it was weird you probably would have
liked it though
maybe yeah it's just weird yeah i like a
lot of things it was just weird
yeah omg i think it was called
john gore says lack of access forced you
to watch things you otherwise wouldn't
that's actually a good point yeah
i mean like i said you had to
you know when i grew up in kind of like
a rednecky town we didn't have like any
good radio stations or anything like
that but we did have
you know i could get mtv i watched 120
minutes we had like um
you know [ __ ]
what was that other thing that uh usa
had night flight it was night flight
right i think that was usa
and so we had that
but
other than that it was kind of like you
had to kind of go word of mouth
um all of the cool like indie flicks
even like even [ __ ] that is like now
well known with like david lynch and
stuff like that that she wouldn't play
in daytona beach [ __ ] that you couldn't
go see that in a theater granters isn't
here but he remembers back in back in
michigan outside detroit
back in the day in the 80s
we had a [ __ ] record store called
harmony house
and me and steve were always on top of
what was cool
because we have friends
with one of the girls that worked at
harmony in that harmony house we called
her harmony house karen oh i got a story
about that to you and steve was hitting
harmony house care and he was a teenager
she was in her early 20s that's just how
it was that he was literally hitting her
he was having sex with her oh yeah
she was like 23 or 24 he was probably
about 18. he was old enough this is an
older woman yeah an older woman
and [ __ ] karen would tell us what
albums to buy gary yeah karen was
looking back on it karen she wasn't a
goth but she was gotha jason
you know what i mean she was like
she would be like a chick that would be
into like jean loves jezebel and [ __ ]
she told me you need to get that jean
love jezebel album that's a good album
it is again that's why i bought that
yeah which one discover uh that was the
porter on it so i think that was that
was before that
it might have been called no it's called
desire i think that's what it was called
well desire was the song
okay my desire the song
rhino the plasti on it yeah that was
disgusting discovery yeah i might have
that did i sell that i have it
i used to have it she told me to get
that album
um
no but karen was she was cute too
but she was probably about 22 i think
she probably wasn't 24 she's probably
about 22.
but you had to know what the [ __ ] was
going on you had to know
people that worked and we called that
working in the industry she worked at
[ __ ] harmony house records
[Laughter]
we'll see but she knew what the records
were she knew
power was different back then
you know i had a similar situation yeah
like i said i grew up in daytona beach
which was it's very rednecky everyone's
like into country or country rock
everyone's very into leonard skynyrd it
was very bike week it was that
but
on beach street
uh
a guy that had graduated from high
school a year or two before me called
eric levin yeah
he actually opened a record store
on that street
uh it was originally called um what was
it called
i know that he called it something that
earlier that got him in trouble with the
law but then he later called it criminal
records because he ended up getting in
trouble but i can't remember what it was
originally called so we call it criminal
records
now eric levin we kind of knew him he
was older than us like uh two or three
years older
but that was the place to go
and once i got into
bauhaus and alien sex scene and stuff
like that he was into that [ __ ] too
so a lot of the times i would go because
uh back then the store was like small
like i think his dad like bought it for
him or whatever and so it was really
little but he would always have like all
these imports and stuff so we would go
in there it's like what you got like
what's good and so we would ask him and
when i got into bauhaus kind of like on
my own and alien sex speed and stuff so
i would go in there i was like what you
got and he was really into bauhaus too
so he was like look i will i'll like
record the [ __ ] for you so and he would
give me stuff like for free so he gave
me masks and he gave me like all these
albums from back then so i got a lot of
[ __ ] from him so i kind of had the same
situation where this guy that was a
couple years older
and he had the means to open his own
record store it actually expanded it
might still be open i'm not entirely
sure i think it's called atlantic sounds
now
um i don't think it's called criminal
roar because i think it's called any
sound
she's asking about my vinyls
all right here's the weird thing i'm
looking in here and the [ __ ] album is
gone
it's gotta be in this stack somewhere
rebel yell
remember that [ __ ]
hell yeah
the original master
dark side of the moon
this this [ __ ] is probably worth a lot
of money
all right
remember this one
jimi hendrix jimi hendrix
electric lady land
i got it
that's an original original
that looks original
yep yeah
damn bowie man who saw the world
okay
original
devo
are we not man
original
director first generator i love that
album okay
original hendrix
yes
yes indeed
axis bold is love
[ __ ] great album that album's in
there
original
billy idol whiplash smile
album is in there
and the record jacket
and the record jacket i got to put that
that in there
this is great out look at the damage
that happened on that
yeah what happened to that i don't know
they're ancient
well yeah minor this one here is gonna i
don't even remember what ones i have
like i have a whole bunch right here and
i can't like even think of this one's
gonna freak dj maniac out
maniac look
the mission god's administration god's
own medicine that's the reference to
heroin
on the goddammit all right
all right
look at this original
labyrinth
labyrinth [ __ ] look at that hot
[ __ ] around there yeah
okay not original reproduction umaguma
relics relics pink floyd relics
okay look original original [ __ ]
release
david bowie
let's dance no no uh never let me down
oh never let me never let you down
that looks like the last dance cover
original hendrix
johnny be good
okay
original
grand ram seven the ragged tiger oh my
god that's awesome yes i used to have
that and i sold it like originals
ray vaughan
that's right
texas flood remember that [ __ ] this is
a [ __ ] good album
okay
immaculate fools original
remember that
holy [ __ ] remember that as an obscure
[ __ ] band you've got a lot of good
[ __ ] i'm gonna take my records down in a
second we'll see what we have in there a
lot of them are gone that's just that's
just what we made yeah mine are too i
sold a bunch because i was broke stevie
ray vaughan couldn't stand the weather
original
that's all i got left that's that's the
last of my vinyl all right let's see
what i got all right let's see what i
got
i'm gonna okay
let me get up here
i can move this thing because there's
the thing that's on top of the thing
and then we'll see
what we got here
okay we're doing our vinyl collection
doing our vinyl collection
i'm gonna do this down here
please forgive me for not being on
camera
but here we go here we go let's see what
jenny's got
i don't even remember what's that what
do i got
this is
bad religion
stranger than fiction
on vinyl don't step on my [ __ ] this is
good [ __ ]
in the cave and the bad seeds the
weeping song
12 inch single
look at that [ __ ] i love this video it's
silica that's so awesome
tunes on town pop
you guys
i love this [ __ ] i love tons of tail
that was in case you don't know that's
daniel ash and kevin haskins from
bauhaus
uh that's another one
yeah it's good it is
also
ooh
julian cope
fried i love this [ __ ] album i love
julian cope you guys he's being the
teardrop explodes which i probably have
on vinyl here somewhere
but i love his [ __ ] album
if you're into pink floyd you'd probably
like julian cope as well like early
julian coke i'm just saying
also got
alien sex fiend this is the 12 inch
single and now i'm feeling zombified
yeah good that's good that's a single
okay yeah it is it's 12 inch single yeah
i used to have curse i don't know what
happened to it
t you need you need to [ __ ] look up
alien sex fiend now i'm feeling
zombified you you'll like that one yeah
echo and the bonnie man oh good yeah
that's good songs to learn insane yeah
this is kind of like their single
compilation
this is one of the first vinyl albums
that i bought it's still in good shape
considering
um all their good [ __ ] is on this do it
clean
uh you know all that i promise back of
love cutter all that
really good [ __ ]
um this is kind of a weird one
it's my halloween horror so that's my
halloween
uh
sound effects at home i have that too
some of you guys will love this
yankovic
in 3d this has nature trail of hell on
it which is my favorite weird song ever
uh this also has what else is on here
i don't even remember
uh eat it which is the beat it uh parody
uh brady bunch buy me a condo i lost on
jeopardy
polka's on party five this is this is
like a super funny album
but nature trail to hell is my absolute
favorite
that's an original song
uh this is
omd someone has someone love on it also
has 88 seconds of greensboro this is a
great [ __ ] album
i love this [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh we got
the damned fantasy oh great album that
is a great album that's nick cave's wife
right there yeah t
if you want to hear a goth album
listen to this one
the phantasmagoria it's a beautiful i
love that it's very good really good
album you want to hear this one and
first and last and always by sisters of
mercy
this one is a little bit more pink
floyd-ish kind of like proto-pink floyd
it's good real good real good
i mean this has shadow of love on it
yeah
and it's got grimly fiendish grimly pink
dishes on it yeah these are the dreams
on there edward the dick absolutely
sure in the back
that's a [ __ ] early goth
powerhouse right there
and now this woman i believe wasn't she
in uh interview the vampire wasn't
didn't she play one of the [ __ ] i
don't know like i said she's the model
i thought she played one of the vampires
she's very friendly
married to nick cave now
yeah
uh
so they've been married a long time but
that's nick cave's wife
i also got let's see
the stranglers
the raven yeah i love the [ __ ]
stranglers
uh yeah
i hate to say but like my ex husband man
seeing this scene this album makes you
want to listen to this the stranglers
are really good by the way
it's hard look how young she is oh yeah
and i forgot this is a 12 inch single
peter murphy line between the devil's
teeth
uh with a strange kind of love version
two on the b side
when peter murphy was like super hot
look at that [ __ ]
he didn't look like that anymore
still crackhead now
although he's playing live nowadays and
i he looks okay he doesn't look super
fat
what i mean
this right here look how dusty this is
this in case you don't know there's no
text on it
this is the same fab testimonial to
listen for later you'll like it this is
the infamous new order blue monday
great album 12-inch single great album
uh very famously if you've ever seen
24-hour party people
yeah they said we lose how much do they
say we lose five dollars every time
somebody buys this album because of like
the way that it was printed they wanted
it to look like a floppy disk you know
what i mean um but
for a long time i don't know about
nowadays but this was the
largest selling 12-inch single
ever
this is blue monday
and i have it
new order we're very into we're not
putting any like [ __ ] [ __ ] on yeah
and that's the original that's an
original and it's in great shape mine
are all [ __ ] up this is it this is
that's mint yeah that's mint i've kept
my [ __ ] in good condition right yeah
this
that petrol emotion do you guys remember
that petrol emotion
they're mostly an irish band but they
had an american singer he was from the
pacific northwest this is groov check
not my favorite song of theirs um but
this is a 12 inch single i was like
really like them
so i have that as well
let's see what's this one oh
this is also peter murphy
this is uh one of his very early singles
blue heart which one is that blue heart
i don't remember that one that's off his
first album should the world fail to
fall apart
okay and uh yeah that's that so like i
said he was very young this was 1980
that's an original very early 80s yes it
is that's original yeah
her shit's in good condition my shit's
all in poor condition
this
is a bootleg
peter murphy exotic
this is a bootleg of a live show that he
did
this is notable
because it has peter murphy peter murphy
covering
purple rain
the prince song
and it's actually a pretty god goddamn
good cover too the audio quality is not
great because it's a bootleg
but
couldn't resist it look how hot that
[ __ ] was back in the old days he
didn't look like that anymore like i
said but
yeah so i have that too
let's see oh i also have this i forgot i
had this what is this even
this is a picture disc
of peter murphy and it's like a
interview i guess it has an interview on
it
i haven't listened with a long time i
don't have a record player but yeah so
this is an interview disc with like
peter murphy on it so i have that
this is uh again peter murphy's first
album should the world fail to fall
apart
from 1986
i think this is
like that
it's a good album it's a little
rudimentary but it's pretty good
deep is better actually love hysteria is
better love history is good
um
deep is good
after that
cascade was good too
after that me not to watch it
i also have
battle house bellagosi's dead
the 12-inch single
which also has
uh boys on the b side
and the longer version of bella goes
he's dead so i have that
in very good condition this is still in
plastic
uh this
is
bauhaus 1979 1983 this is all their
kind of uh singles and whatnot
also very very good condition yeah also
in very good conditions this is like all
they're good and that album is what i
remember this from high school
grantors isn't on there but i remember
[ __ ] jason quinlan had this album
this is this is the album that he had
that introduced me to bauhaus yeah
man
[ __ ] it a little bit it's got a little
bit mold on it i haven't seen this i
haven't seen this since high school yeah
[ __ ] look at what all is on there look
at that this album is so good
this album is [ __ ] awesome if you
don't know anything about goth music
this is kind of the album you should
start with
they've got all their best [ __ ] on yeah
it's got all their it's a double album
you want to start with this one
and you want to what's on here
double dare in the flat field dark
countries big motta martyr bella goes
he's dead oh yeah telegram sam which is
a uh cover say invite his dance spy in
the cab tear a couple guys like
everything every service in fairy fair
you want bills everything you want this
double album and you want sisters of
mercy first and last and always and this
is the goth primer
yeah that's once you have this double
head and the other one then you go oh
and then maybe like the
the first [ __ ] skinny puppy album
bites
and then you go like oh [ __ ] okay that's
kind of where it came from
damn jenny we gotta listen to this [ __ ]
i told you
we need a record player
yeah we do also records sounded better
than digital because it was analog
well yeah it wasn't well because cds and
mp3s are compressed like they
press everything down into like a
smaller like bandwidth t says that is
one beautiful album cover yes it was
that that was their logo this [ __ ]
album kind of changed my musical
direction in life back in high school i
listened to this and this ended the
metal era
it was like oh okay well for you it did
for me
the middle era yeah this one and uh
first and last and always did you show
that yet
i don't think it will that's it toward
the bottom okay all right
i also have
the bubble men are coming
which if you don't know
this is
the 11 rockets side band yeah they all i
don't know if it was them but they
dressed up in like bubble man costumes
and like
did
a couple of songs
uh in the costumes
and this is actually still a good song
but yeah so i have that god man i can't
remember how classy that [ __ ] looked i
told you what to do t this [ __ ] here is
classy and spooky
this is a [ __ ] spooky double album i
love that [ __ ] and it's [ __ ] great
man i want to listen to this
well we'll have to buy a record player
to get a record fire yeah got tones on
tail that's kind of like this is kind of
like not pop but it's like all of their
hits on one thing like i said tones on
tail if you don't know was danny lash
and kevin haskins from
bauhaus and eleven rockets this was
their band in between that there was
also glenn kampling who was a roadie for
bauhaus at the time and they had a band
for a short time and they're actually
quite awesome
um if you like dance music if you like
kind of like dark dance music you should
totally yeah this is a good band too it
kind of had all of these from this one
yeah yeah but for me
this is where it was but you know what i
mean i'm a traditionalist
me too in a lot of ways but oh and this
is one of my favorites oh [ __ ]
birthday party junkyard i don't know
oh this is such a good album
birthday party if you don't know
was nick cave's
well it wasn't his first band because he
was in the boys next door but then like
the boys next door
became the birthday party now the
birthday party
is one of my favorite bands ever it's
punk it's blues they're australian
uh so it's an australian punk
version
of an american interpretation of blues
and it is [ __ ] up and crazy and i love
it
this album is
not my favorite i think my favorite of
theirs is probably the ep that they did
that had jennifer's veil and stuff on it
but this one is fantastic this one has
she's hit this one has big jesus trash
can this one has dead joe on it this one
has dim locator which i love which is
underrated this is a [ __ ] great
great
album audrey i love this [ __ ] adriana
says daniel ash and peter murphy hotness
overload in the day back in the day in
the day daniel daniel i haven't seen him
in a while last time i saw him which was
a while back he still looked pretty hot
yeah peter murphy not so much she's
talking about she's talking about these
two right here
you need them right here she's talking
about those two right there yeah
yeah yeah back in those days those are
the crap you couldn't get hotter than
that yeah goth goth dudes did not get
any hotter than that back in those days
those are the archetypes peter murphy
was kind of like the hottest [ __ ] ever
yeah that's the guy that's [ __ ] in
the clown sweater
yeah the other one is daniel ash
daniel ash pretty hot too yeah although
gotta say
of all the dudes in bauhaus
daniel ash i mean they were all hot i'm
not saying that it was kind of like a
duran duran situation they're all hot
and like if you have to rank them you
feel bad yeah but
peter murphy hottest gonna say kevin
haskins and david j were kind of like
yeah i i thought they were hotter they
were kind of nerdier but i'm kind of
into that now peter murphy was [ __ ] a
friend of ours all right yeah and uh
that [ __ ] [ __ ] he's a dick there's
like well everyone they're gonna be a
dick that they're from the dick era all
right
uh the dick area they're from the dick
area that's where tom comes from
you could be a dick to your fans
uh it didn't work out though in the long
run
but you know what musically great guys
musically great [ __ ] um honestly they
changed a lot of stuff bauhaus's mask
yeah is still one of my favorite albums
mask is a great album right it is i like
that one i mean the first album is good
too
but
mask is good because
they dipped into a lot of different this
is going back to what we're saying
earlier
they dipped into a lot of different
musical styles there's some reggae on
there there's some kind of proto metal
on there there's all kind of stuff but
it still like works as a cohesive whole
it's like really really good
yeah and they had class
they had very good taste well they were
into very good taste their whole thing
was they were into well the reason they
chose the name bauhaus was because they
were into like early 20th century
architectural or like the architectural
like artistic style of the time
so a lot of the images they used were
from silent movies they used like a lot
of stuff from like nosferatu and um you
know
dr caligari stuff like that so they were
really into that whole kind of like
german look they were into german
expressionism so they were into that
whole like look and they were kind of
into that sound too but they were like
trying to like modernize that
look yeah into a modern day sound they
were also into like glam they they're
awesome did like [ __ ] punk
reggae and they kind of like mix that
into their own yeah
tea
get that album listen to that [ __ ]
i mean that's got all their best [ __ ]
you understand i think it it's just uh
guys in the 80s
white dudes in the 80s who were [ __ ]
kind of like in the dark underbelly
trying to hearken back to another era
but also mixing in what was happening to
them at that time it was rock and retro
and gothic and dark at the same time
they were very very good and
instrumental
in their place and time
um
pre-internet
there was
[ __ ] tons of control over the
information flow
this busted out from the underground no
one no one could stop it crazy kids like
us were listening to it going oh man
hell yeah
today it wouldn't be noticed i don't
think uh but you got rock dudes like
starry night who are friends of ours who
love that
it's just that it's the times have
changed i mean it's easier to find it
easier like i said is good right this
album was something that you had to one
know what it was and you would have to
know where to find it there weren't many
of these i can't even remember where i
bought that
where did i buy that i think i bought
that at atlantic sounds in daytona
actually it was um he got it for me it
was underground [ __ ] it was like i don't
remember how much
cause look you guys saw my reaction i
didn't know you had that yeah i haven't
seen that since high school
that's i've had that all this time i
don't even remember like how much i paid
for that probably like more that i could
afford quite a lot at the time yeah i
think i bought it make many of those i
think i bought it and atlantic sounds
right in the early 90s maybe late 80s or
early 90s look at that [ __ ] i don't
remember how much it cost me though it
was it was an import back then so it
probably was very expensive it's a style
i think i paid 30 dollars for that it's
a stylized
profile of a face
in in metal well like i said that's
that's that's very that's kind of like
the bauhaus the bauhaus style style from
the german nintendo
yeah yeah they kind of like modified
chips yeah because they were really into
that right they were really into that oh
we got a [ __ ] super chat thank you
very much
oh [ __ ]
thank you
thank you but judd must understand
you're awesome if you want all right let
me we're good let me do this down
because show them the rest of the vinyl
you guys okay i just i only have like
three or four more okay yeah this is
modern english after the snow oh man
that's you guys that's a good album you
only know like yeah i melt with you
which is an amazing song however is good
this came out in 1982 i bought this in
1982 when it came out
and it's still like in really good
condition surprisingly because i don't
like [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
the rest of this album is
amazing
i kind of feel like people just know i
melt with you which like i said is good
because that's a good song
but the rest of this album is
i love this album so much yeah i bought
this album in 1982.
this is one of the first albums the
first album that i bought with my own
money because i was like only 11.
yeah that's what she's talking about the
first album i bought with my own money
in case anybody wanted to know was
synchronicity by the police which i also
love
this was i think the second one
and i listened to this
so this whole album is
amazing yes i melt with you is amazing
yeah but the rest of this album yeah is
as good or better than that it's very
very proto-goth i feel like yeah
it's tv i don't know i know that song
she likes it yeah you will love that
this album is so good the album's really
good the whole album is good yeah the
whole enemy is good that i'm gonna [ __ ]
you up this album is so good have you
ever heard of that i've heard that
i love it
so let's see what this next one is
surprise i forgot what i had
this is uh oh this is another one it's
like blood curdling sounds of terror i
have like a lot of
old school halloween albums everybody's
leaving the show we only got 17 in there
now
oh well hey man we're talking about
albums yeah
also there's this one which is spooky
sounds and like scary stories so i have
that too i don't know that one
and then we have what is this
this is i mentioned this earlier this is
the teardrop explodes kilimanjaro
another one of my favorite albums of all
time
julian cope yeah uh he's a welsh fella
and he was in teardrop explodes they did
two albums kilimanjaro and wilder
and then he went off on his own now his
solo stuff is good too
but teardrop explodes
i
[Music]
[ __ ] love their [ __ ] and i kind of
feel like maybe nowadays people don't
know much about it it's weird it's a
little bit if you're into like pink
floyd like especially like pink floyd
like sid barrett type of stuff
i kind of feel like you'd probably be
into this too because this is very like
um
80s
throwback to like psychedelia of the 60s
you know what i mean it's that kind of
thing so if you like that then you would
probably like this as well but i love
this [ __ ] album so yeah amy says i
didn't know bad english was goth wow
yeah modern english not yeah yeah yeah
that was modern english modern english
was
goth you know yeah and goth new wave
we listen to it we listen to it
dead kennedy's
halloween
12-inch single
i got that for 50 cents as you can see
yeah
what is that dad kennedy is oh which one
is that halloween i don't know that one
and here you go this is the one that you
were waiting for this is first and last
and always oh yeah yeah yeah my vinyl
you have it i don't have it i have it in
vinyl [ __ ] okay look i'm cooler than you
officially yeah all right look
i'm gonna [ __ ] reach out the [ __ ]
t
i showed you that bauhaus album that was
what 1979 to 1983 was the name of the
house double album
this is the other one that you should
have
it's sisters of mercy
the first and last and always
if you ask me as far as single albums go
this is the best gothic rock album of
all times yeah if you want to know what
like gothic rock is it's this
start with that you're right start with
that this is the pink floyd dark side of
the moon for gothic rock albums okay
this is andrew eldritch and those spooky
little [ __ ] right there
this is this is their first full-length
album they came out with this one and
then they broke up after this
andrew owned the name sisters of mercy
and he the band continued
kind of like a solo act
the band continued at on as mission uk
yeah
all right which mission uk is great too
but really this album this album
was
the best [ __ ] goth album of all times
if you ask me and does it have the inner
sleeve it doesn't it doesn't have the
[ __ ] normally the version i had
the inner sleeve had a picture of them
standing outside the majestic theater in
detroit
because andrew and that's him right
there
and he he was a british guy
andrew actually thought detroit was the
most gothic of all cities it was a place
where all the manholes steamed even
though he would was knock off
yeah he claimed not to be gotham okay
that [ __ ] invented a lot of god [ __ ]
but he wanted he was so goth he couldn't
say he was guth
that's very gothic yeah
i'm not god's son the names of the songs
on this album are black planet
okay black planet on the edge of the
highway running down highway 101. the
black planet if you ask me i think he's
talking about the moon all right
well it's an eclipse it's an eclipse all
right
walk away is no time to cry
every single song
mary anne [ __ ] that's the gothic
nationalism
every time marianne to this day they
still play this [ __ ] came out how long
did this go to this 1984 was it
84 83 a long time ago okay 85 85 85.
they still play marianne
at the club in goth clubs to this day
and sometimes black planet but usually
marianne marianne and
dances side is first and last and always
and on everybody
[ __ ] great song
possession
a [ __ ] great song all right
[ __ ] nine wild nine that's my
favorite yeah yeah nine more nights
right then
logic but they [ __ ] it's amphetamines
it's actually called amphetamine logic
but they couldn't say that in that era i
used to have the
logic i used to have the
cassette tape yeah and it actually did
say amphetamine amphetamine
but they couldn't they couldn't say
amphetamine like on a lot of stuff so
they took that out they had they but i
used to have a tape that said that but
at the time there were industry
standards they couldn't make drug
references yeah but it's actually called
it's called amphetamine amphetamine
logic yeah and [ __ ] um and then the
last song on the album is called some
kind of stranger goddammit another
[ __ ] great one that's my second
favorite right on that but this is it's
like it's so epic it's epic but this is
a it's an epic song about a one-night
stand i mentioned this album on the show
before and have had people contact me
over fit over [ __ ] facebook
people i don't even [ __ ] know
said i want to thank you for
recommending that album because i can't
stop listening to this album and these
are like teenage kids
saying i can't stop listening to this
album
this is a [ __ ] deep dark
enlightening album of these spooky ass
[ __ ] white boys
okay
bringing you the gothic gestalt okay
and uh and what's funny is that they're
young dudes they're like in their 20s
but it sounds like old men talking to
you well see that's why i needed like
joy division that's what was great about
them yeah yeah
because
that's why it was like joy division
because yeah ian curtis
he's like singing
like he's like [ __ ] 80 year old man
and he's like [ __ ]
19 or some [ __ ] like that yeah and you
would never know and then he killed
himself and he was like 23. it's like
[ __ ] crazy yeah i thought she said
she edited it and [ __ ] she's
interested in seeing [ __ ] final
records
yeah it's just
t
listen to that one and the behind i had
honestly i had more than that because i
used to have one of the ones that i
remembered just now when you were
talking
i used to have
echo in the body men
porcupine which is one of their first
albums which was like a double album and
i used to have that or it was like at
least a gate uh gatefold
and i don't know what happened to it
maybe i sold it because when i lived in
my old apartment
uh
i was broke and i sold a lot of my vinyl
because i needed some money
and i kind of feel like maybe that's one
of the ones that i sold which bums me
out now that i'm thinking about it
but i used to have a lot more vinyl than
that that's just like the old vinyl that
i have and the last one that i have and
i think i showed this on the show before
you guys are going to laugh
where did i quebec dare to be stupid
which has uh what's on this
like a surgeon dare to be stupid uh one
more minute which is
one more minute
that's an original song i think and uh
that's amazing
yoda which is a parody of lola by the
kinks which is also amazing
um
slime creatures amount of space i think
that's an original girls just want to
have lunch yeah this is like super fun
super fun i'm a big weirdo fan i know
that's like weird but
i have so i have a couple of this [ __ ]
on vinyl but i used to have a lot more
than that on vinyl but
i sold a bunch
when i was poor
and
now i'm kind of like regretting it
because like i said i used to have
i'm thinking of like [ __ ] that i used to
have on vinyl
i mean the one that i'm particular that
i'm remembering i used to have echo in
the bunny been porking my porcupine on
vinyl and now i don't have it anymore
so i must have sold it that sucks
well
you know uh tila says oh my god it's so
interesting seeing final records yeah i
kind of wish i had more than that like i
don't have anything to play them on we
don't have a record player
but
i couldn't i didn't really have the
heart to get rid of these ones
and like i said i used to have oh
another one that i used to have was um
what was that omd album that had sew and
love on it oh what was the name of that
but the one that came out in like 82 i
want to say
orchestral maneuvers in the dark i used
to have that on vinyl too
um which is a great album and
i kind of feel like i probably sold that
so i used to have like
probably way more vinyl than that
[ __ ] i used to have a [ __ ] style
that [ __ ] i did too
yeah well like i said remember when i
used to live at that apartment on aloma
yeah um
i had like
probably like two-thirds more than that
and i sold them
yeah uh so i'm looking through my
because i'm remembering a lot of i'm now
that i'm looking through that stuff i'm
remembering like a lot of vinyl that i
used to have that i don't have anymore
and it's kind of bumping me out yeah and
vinyl did sound better
there was yeah it had a lot of resonant
frequencies involved in it it was more
it wasn't digital it was uh
just more ambient sounding it's just uh
you have resonant frequencies coming out
of stuff well it's more acoustic
it was it was it was analog it just
sounded like well like i said um the
thing about cd mp3 stuff like that is
that to
translate that sound into that format
you have to compress the sound so it's
not as
when you listen to an album it's a lot
wider
yeah you know what i mean there's a lot
like um there's a lot more space yeah to
it she's asking did we clean the albums
i think we just kind of wiped him down
with the with the with the with the rag
yeah there's like a little rag it was
like a little velvet thing yeah yeah
it's like it was like a little eraser
but
the eraser pad had a velvet on it yeah
and uh
i think we sometimes hit them with a
little bit of alcohol
yeah and take the dirt out of them
uh it was mostly more important back in
the days to change your your photograph
needle
oh that too yeah they had a bunch of
different needles you could use
yeah some of them [ __ ] were like more
narrow and they did certain things
and you had to have a stereo with an
amplifier and good speakers it was all
analog
there that particular album remember
first last and always from sisters of
mercy when they digitized it
and put it on a cd it lost a lot of its
ambient there's red
sound quite this didn't quite sound the
same
it sounded a lot better on [ __ ] vinyl
on a good on a good record
uh you could hear harmonies and [ __ ]
resonant frequencies between
bass and guitar and
[ __ ] sounded a little bit better the
digital versions are okay
just not as good as the original record
i don't think i don't think the
re
i don't think the engineering
but
taking it from record or vinyl to
digital they didn't do a real good job
of people well you can see why hipsters
are like way more so that's why like
bands nowadays are still releasing stuff
on vinyl
because it does
yeah it does sound better it sounds more
real
well there's more
i don't
what's the word
there's kind of like a more like there's
more
realness there's more
it's there some sounds like they're in
the room with you yeah there's more like
tangibility yeah
it sounds like it's there
right which like i said
digital stuff like i said i got used to
like the cd stuff and the mp3s and it's
almost as good yeah but when you listen
to vinyl particularly over headphones
um it gives you a different they
actually feel like it actually feels
like it's
there with you yeah in a kind of living
way that
doesn't really translate to digital
right uh formats now t i'm gonna say
this and i say this i have said this
before but i'm saying it fully in public
in front of you people [ __ ] live
the best album of all times is dark side
of the moon from pink floyd
but right there with it right there with
it
it's first and last and always from
scissors to the mercy
in my opinion
and i showed you guys that album earlier
and people who are not even goths have
come back and said man thank you for
talking about that album that is the
best album of all kinds you put that
[ __ ] in your car stereo and you won't
take it out of there it's just this
somber
rock
that feels sounds very deep and very
minor key and very kind of like and his
passing slowly killing time was
better than living i i can't do it i
can't do it when you see it when you
listen to it you'll understand
it's just has a very deep
and somber
sound to it it sounds very important
it sounds like you're listening to
something very important and these wise
men are telling you things
okay this is like does this sound like
that way jenny does yeah yeah and uh
that bauhaus double album though is like
right there but the vibe is a little bit
different well that's a different vibe
because bauhaus like i said were they
were angrier and more experimental and
yeah a lot of people like to like
classify them as a goth band which they
were
but
they had a whole bunch of other [ __ ]
going on there's reggae on that album
the whole bunch well the best thing
about bauhaus in my opinion and the
reason why they broke up after like four
or five years
was because there were four very
different individuals that were into
four very different kinds of music
and that
came together
uh for a little while
and
captured lightning in a bottle it was
just like this kind of
amalgamation yeah of like all this cool
[ __ ] from like all these like
underground genres
but that couldn't sustain itself
yeah but
i love
like i said bauhaus's mask is one of my
favorite albums of all time just because
it's all over the place yeah it's
[ __ ] goth it's reggae it's metal it's
like they did everything but it still
works it still like works as a cohesive
whole which is amazing now maniac says
comes in and says did that if i knew
that public enemy and [ __ ] they
didn't
it was two diametrically opposed
racial scenes
[ __ ] they chased the white kids off
i do remember when they were it was
ahead of their times but the creators
understood what was going on the
creators knew
a lot of people knew uh it's just that
the hood didn't know yet they didn't
know where any of this came from um
they didn't have access to the
information they didn't know
but no yeah i knew that that happened
and and then what was funny is that you
know the run dmc aerosmith crossover
worked on the white side didn't work on
the black i mean that was a massive deal
i remember one of the things that was a
massive deal because i like to run dmc
too they were good also
uh like i said
white kids in that era were listening to
black music well you have to think too
that like at that time when that song
when that single broke right aerosmith
were not i mean they were old
i mean that was like old white people
yeah
it wasn't like oh we're the young kids
or anything they were old at that time
now tila counters this though she said
prince toured with rolling stones and he
got booed the thing is that the rolling
stones fans were much older than the
prince fans that's what i'm saying much
older yeah uh
not excusing it i'm just saying yeah not
excusing it it's just that the rolling
stones fans were old
um no but if you were to if if that were
to roll today
that show would be a hit prints and
rolling stones yeah that'd be it yeah
well i mean that that was another one
that was still alive you're right
that would probably fly yeah fly now
yeah
but that's why though i mean
the reason that like i said i kind of
feel like
that's why
as much as like some [ __ ] about like the
70s and 80s
not the 90s because [ __ ] that right yeah
but the 70s
90s could be good too well there was
some good every now and then
i was not a big fan of the 90s as as a
decade i don't know man but 70s and 80s
i kind of liked nirvana i thought they
were good i liked neurotics i liked
alice in chains i thought they were good
[ __ ] somebody gave me
uh somebody gave me a kim lab was 90s
and they were good i know
i'm not saying there wasn't anything
good from the 90s there was i'm just
saying that overall
i was not a fan of the direction that
the 90s went i'm not saying that there
wasn't anything good in the 90s because
there was
and
i like nirvana too like look somebody
gave me like
even before
uh nirvana got super famous
i got a couple of their albums free
because like i said i was broke so some
people are like hey i'll record the
album i bought it i'll record it for you
so that's what we used to do you'd get
the record or the cd or the you know
cassette and you would tape it for your
friends because
they're broke like me
and i'm like i want to hear that
so i got like the nirvana album and
i kind of feel the weird thing about
this and i think i've mentioned this
before 1981 when that
nirvana uh single came out it smells
like team spirit yeah
i first saw it on 120 minutes the
you know underground music show which
mtb did at it was like midnight on
sundays or something it was like two
hours not a drink yeah
so they did that and it's like i saw
that song i'd heard nirvana before
because i'd heard about they had an
album before that which was called
bleach
and i was like so i heard them before
and that song came out and i was like
man that's a pretty good song man i
can't can't see that ever being like
popular
little did i know
that
literally that like the next day
everybody would be into that [ __ ]
everybody
and it was just like [ __ ] crazy it
was just like a crazy [ __ ] because i
never thought that that song
that song
it's a great song
but
nirvana and
had he still been alive kurt cobain
would have said this as well
was essentially
a pixies song
but
yeah
and i mean nirvana were very open about
their pixies influence
uh the whole thing about soft cloud soft
loud they got that from the pixies and
they were very open about that and so
i kind of feel like i i feel like that's
maybe where a lot of the
resentment
uh
of our people came from because it's
like look we've been listening to the
pixies i barely see the pixies at that
point for
several years and it's like look nirvana
came along it's like oh they're doing
what the pixies are doing but they're
doing a more grungy version of the
pixies which okay that's cool
and now suddenly everybody loves that
[ __ ] and i'm just kind of like okay but
like the pixies have been doing that for
a long time and also like nirvana i've
been along around
before that too
and
there was that too so it was just kind
of like when everybody kind of loved it
suddenly you were kind of like okay
where did that come from yeah it i don't
know it was just it was a very weird
time it was a very weird time so i kind
of feel like that
fed into why i wasn't a big fan of the
90s but i did like nirvana i had that
whole
the whole first couple albums i had
bleach i had
uh never mind
uh before it broke
because somebody taped it for me
and
i don't know it's
like i said it was a weird time it was a
weird time
but
teetha said i had really good hear
really good things about dark side the
moon pink floyd
depends on the genre but so many good
albums if you haven't heard pink if you
haven't heard dark side of the moon then
you've never really heard
a good album
sorry
some people say listen to it alongside
wizard of oz yeah
no
don't do that
that's expert level [ __ ]
and and that was all [ __ ] anyway
what you do is you sit down the thing is
is that came from a time
when an album was like an opera
all right and that genre of music one
song wasn't enough
you had to put the album on and listen
to the whole side of the album and then
flip it over and listen to the other
side and you're basically listening to a
show an album
it's the mix is perfect
on dark side of the moon it takes you
through a journey
if you have something visual to look at
if you're kind of maybe getting a little
bit high smoking some weed you're
looking at something projected on the
ceiling you have to immerse yourself in
that album it was another genre another
medium of entertainment
most pink floyd albums were designed to
be
a product consumed
as a whole
you listen to the whole album
you listened to dark side of the moon
you listened to the wall which was i
think it was a double album
it was and then you listened to metal or
metally it's called metal i think
uh or echoes echoes that was the name of
that album echo you listen to echoes
[ __ ] it was just a good albums you
know and once you heard one song you
wanted to hear the next one anyway
you know
wow it was from a slower time
it was like a time of meditation and
reflection and introspection and they're
taking you on a journey
it wasn't uh the modern era where
it's these little [ __ ] instagram
videos and photographs where
everything's like two or three
no it's not like they're taking i get
that but
like there's something to be said for
a really good
short like single because like i said
that's why i love punk rock like a short
like i said the damned early damned
we're really good at that new rose right
um [ __ ] like that fantasmagoria
is like a [ __ ]
pink floyd album you won't listen to the
whole album yeah because they're taking
that but yeah
there is a like what she says short
stuff does work yeah the the humans it
depends on what mood you're in yeah
right here um do you just want like a
single it's just like a short two three
minutes pop song yeah that's just gonna
like uplift your mutually and i'm not
[ __ ] on that because that's good too
like i said and punks did that too yeah
um honestly a lot of uh punk songs i
like like i said the damn but even later
on like bad religion they would do a
song that wasn't even two minutes they
would just like come in and they would
like [ __ ] hit you with the [ __ ] it
was like an amazing like melody an
amazing like [ __ ] beat and then they
were just like do it for less than two
minutes and then they were gone they got
their message through and that was it
and i that's there's something to be
said for that but
there's all there's also something to be
said for somebody that
does a whole album
thinking that someone's going to like
lay down
and listen to this whole thing all right
and that was a lot of the good [ __ ] yeah
not just prague rock
prague rock they knew you were going to
sit there and listen to that whole
[ __ ] album sitting on a bean bag
smoking a [ __ ] doobie
with a dude [ __ ] sitting next to you
who's your buddy and you're looking at
lava lamps and you got colored lights in
the room
and you're just being immersed and
you're being taken to this other world
it's like theater it's like opera
okay
some of the gothic stuff that i told you
about was kind of like that more driving
music like you're driving in your car or
you're sitting around listening to this
[ __ ] dude telling you [ __ ]
you know the first and last and always
album is kind of like that
joy division albums are kind of like
that
although i will you on heroin with
colored lights and [ __ ] tripping and
going i will say somewhere you know joy
divisions closer which came out in 1980
came out a little bit after ian curtis
uh hanged himself
that album
i saw this like back in the old days i
was like somebody said this is the best
album to listen to like in complete
sensory deprivation yeah and so i
decided i'm gonna try that [ __ ] out that
sounds like a good because i loved that
album yeah so i blacked out all my
windows
like blacked out the sound everything
that i just laid there and i just
let myself listen to it and
that person was absolutely correct
that album needs yeah sensory
deprivation you need no no other sound
no other
sights no other nothing just like
but t is going damn i need to get me
some bean bags and some colored lights
yes yes that's what the it was another
time
you didn't have all these screens it's
hard because like even now like look i'm
old like i'm almost 50. and even now
it's like it's hard for me to like pull
myself away from a screen yeah and
screens just like lay down and like lay
down on a couch and like read a book
like a physical book because i've been
reading a lot of ebooks lately or just
like lay down like listen to an album
because i kind of feel like oh i should
be doing something else and it's like
that's that sucks and we we shouldn't
feel like what you did was you and your
friends got together in this little room
you want bean bags
if you're smoking a [ __ ] hookah
or you've got bongs or you're smoking
some weed and you got a real good stereo
system it's dark in there you got a
black light going and black light
posters some [ __ ]
pixies on top of [ __ ] mushrooms or
just whatever
and then you're gonna and you're going
to it's like going to the movies
and you're going into this album
all right
a lot of the albums a lot of the prog
rock was like that some of the early
goth was like that because that culture
was still going on pre-internet culture
and it was the it was the genre it was
it was the medium of the time it was the
social media of the time
and it was it was good it was very good
i like them both
it was low information by today's
standards
but information meant more you didn't
know as much but what you did know you
clutched on to it as if it was like
little [ __ ] pearls little diamonds
yeah like oh i know something somebody
else doesn't know it was a different era
yeah
and
it was a more charming era
if you ask me
you could be dumb and still be cool and
you didn't know that you were done
because you just didn't know the
information wasn't being presented to
you
you didn't have an internet where
any question you had could be answered
back in those days you had to go to a
library and half them damn books were
lying
or inaccurate you know they were they're
inaccurate because they were old they
were old you know so it didn't matter it
was a time of mystery
in many ways
although today is a time of mystery
because we kind of you know in a
different way it's in a different way
because a lot now you have many because
now you have like a lot of information
and they're uh they all [ __ ] most of
them are
bullshitting
and you're not entirely sure you're not
sure which one it is right so that's so
it's kind of the same but it's not as
romantic right
it was a more romantic time t you liked
it you liked it because it's not that
different it's just right right right
we we still we have access to more
information but that doesn't really mean
that we have more information yeah
because we have access to more [ __ ]
he said there's nothing like listening
to the pink uh dark side of the middle
when you're shrimp tripping on shrimps
yeah and here's the thing she said her
husband said that yeah and here's the
thing
if you listen to the dark side of the
moon
it's not making unsupported claims it's
not making it's
it's a very normal [ __ ]
that they're talking about
the commentary is very normal
but it's just that you hadn't really
realized it
you know what i mean you're like yeah
yeah that's right
either
it's just when you'll see it when you
listen to it you'll understand
you like you'll understand it's very
very human
it's not bullshitting it's just well as
i said
that's kind of what we're going back
um to why i think that bands like pink
floyd or the smiths for example
are kind of like universal across
generations yeah because they're
con
it's weird because like conversely
they're talking about their own personal
experiences yeah but by talking about
their personal experiences they're
translating to everyone because everyone
right
feels that right
okay
in in in today's in today's vernacular
you would call it it's amsr
that's what it's like
in those days you'd call it intimacy
you're listening to somebody else's
thoughts and you're kind of like
resonating with it you're like going
like yeah
yeah i know i know how you feel
yeah that's exactly what it is and yes
this is exactly what society does to us
this is what they're telling us
but we know it's not true
and we know our place in life and we
know their place in life
and we know they're full of [ __ ]
it's just you you'll see you'll see
you'll see you just gotta listen to it
it's a universal norm
it's the way life has been
and you know you guys know i'm a student
of history
two three thousand years at least
there are universal constants
and and floyd was good with that
flip is very good with that but then
they'd also even call [ __ ] on the
record industry because they made
records for a living and they [ __ ]
come back and turn in on themselves and
go record industry is full of [ __ ] and
you're listening to this record so it
was kind of meta
it was it was meta for its day
uh but no they uh but uh you know
now t was saying earlier on
we're talking about we're talking about
pink floyd that's americans or that's
british stuff
t was asking well okay uh what's better
tom jones or elvis i'm gonna say both
yeah that's the thing that's a hard
distinction to make both
jones
i love tom jones and i love elvis welsh
yes [ __ ] had a range he was a
crooner elvis ended up kind of being a
crooner too
um very emotional
both good-looking guys big good-looking
guys
but we got to say got to say something
about jones jones confirmed huge [ __ ]
confirmed
he put cassandra peterson in the
hospital
that's right i forgot about that she's
known as elvira yeah
yeah he went anal on her and put her in
the hospital she had to get stitches
after that [ __ ]
it was an accident but jones
[ __ ] was huge okay i have heard
that and he's a good looking dude good
looking dude i told you i lived in wales
for a long time and they are very very
proud of tom jones over there they love
[ __ ] i do not question
which he's pretty awesome guys i do not
question wales's pride in tom jones yes
just cool tom jones was the man i know
you've never been there but it's like
i've been there i was like whale's
pretty cool he was a [ __ ] man
they're very proud of tom jones elvis
was very similar you guys know i'm
southern i'm a [ __ ] child of
mississippi elvis rules i love it elvis
was just
70 miles from where i lived houston
tupelo from i'm from [ __ ] heidelberg
okay mississippi
uh me and elvis have a lot in common uh
culturally
and just roots wise
i didn't re i got to be honest man i
liked elvis as a guy [ __ ] i
understand exactly what he did there's a
lot of [ __ ] negative [ __ ] about elvis
that they'll say is a lie okay elvis was
very cool
um
elvis i didn't really like it i didn't
really didn't like his music that much
he elvis was
gospel i like that though i'm not really
into that but
but some of his [ __ ] was just [ __ ]
awesome it was [ __ ] banging
okay
he was an alpha of his day
the elvis and nixon movie was the [ __ ]
and [ __ ] that passes the [ __ ]
truth test the smell test his friends
said yeah that's what it was like when
elvis met nixon he was a [ __ ] trip
he wasn't
he wasn't what a lot of people might
think you know i mean he he was kind of
a
southern goth kind of guy for his time
um he wasn't a racist that was chuck d
and [ __ ] guys from public enemy that
came out said he he actually liked black
people he grew up around black people
he sang black music for his time a lot
they were very conservative southerners
didn't like elvis because he sounded too
black
yeah i don't think he was trying to do
anything
he was he was just singing music that he
liked
and that was like i don't think he
thought about it he was in a time of
segregation a lot of black artists
couldn't play in a white venue that's
what i'm saying like it's problematic
from today's stance right but i don't
think that he thought of it that way no
a lot of [ __ ] white people wanted to
hear black music they just did
elvis could deliver that because he
could play in those venues yeah but that
was in the very early years of his
career yeah
the america had was changing the south
was changing at that time
his music
rapidly by the time the 60s came along
was retro and old-fashioned
elvis was a traditional guy he he saw
the beatles and he's like oh i don't
know if i could bring myself that's not
music which is hilarious yeah which is
kind of hilarious because nowadays
nobody nobody sees the beatles
problematic you're right he's in any way
whatsoever
had elvis held on for a while
he actually could have
had he not died
he actually could have come back with
with [ __ ] like the stray cats and
brought his
that's what i mean early 80s was very
into very much as [ __ ] yeah they were
very interactive like i said you have
the stray cats who are mainstream you
have like people like the cramps you had
like the whole kind of like rockabilly
revival even clandestine pole cats all
that kind of glenn danzig and the
misfits and sure misfits glenn danzig
and all that he totally could have wrote
that way could have come back with that
he could have read that way he didn't
know
and uh there were drug problems
which i don't totally blame him i mean
the fact that he wasn't real up on i
mean the fact that he was like kind of
culturally conservative might have like
hindered him in a lot of ways because if
he had
been hep to the [ __ ]
he would have known that the early 80s
right were a big
everybody was like 50s revival was kind
of a big
sub genre like like you said stray cats
pole cats
um you know you had all the cramps you
had all this kind of stuff that was like
looking back it was coming back to what
he had 50s right like through an 80s
lens so had he come back well look what
[ __ ] um look what johnny cash did
right later on
where he was kind of like look
everybody's into this kind of like
creepy
country [ __ ] like in the late 80s early
90s and he came back and he was
successful i wouldn't the cave covered
the [ __ ] right he covered the nick cave
song for christ's sake so now you said
cultural conservatism that's only part
of it what it was is he was just trying
to be southern and he was trying
to be traditional from a southern point
of view
even though he was a rebel in the south
which that's there's a paradox there i
know but he's trying to redefine what
the south is
um but i i talked about it early on in
other shows with personal experience and
understandings of biology of what really
happened to elvis
what happened to elvis was [ __ ] um
menopause
okay
his testosterone levels declined
and he thought he was sick so he started
to take drugs to make himself feel
better
had elvis been on hrt a lot of the bad
things that happened to elvis would have
never happened but they didn't know back
then human biology
he was a very high energy guy
born famous was a soldier
conquered being a [ __ ] soldier in
germany married his commander his
commanding general's daughter who was a
[ __ ] gorgeous prize everything was
this winning winning winning winning
winning
elvis didn't know losing
as soon as [ __ ] his androgens
started to drop off and as soon as he
wasn't really on top of the game he got
depressed and his [ __ ] hormonal
levels [ __ ]
depleted he got depressed and he thought
he was sick that's not what it was
he needed test he'd have been a lot
better
um
a lot of guys go through it what was it
called not uh andrenopods he hit
andrenopos
modern technology could have fixed him
but he thought he had some kind of
sickness
well back then they didn't know they
didn't know well and a lot of that was
because
i kind of feel like they just
i don't know it was kind of like this
understanding that like if you
weren't like happy with your life or
whatever like yeah they didn't really
have like a big understanding of like
mental health issues they didn't know
anything about they didn't know anything
about [ __ ] body they didn't really
know much about biology either yeah not
really and nothing about life extension
you just [ __ ] drank yourself to death
from an early age
you ate lots of beef and drink pork
juice
that's you know what i mean which until
your [ __ ] arteries hardened and that
yeah that's like like my chicken
yeah that was kind of like my my
grandparents yeah not so much my parents
were my grandparents right uh aaron uh
modern knowledge would have saved elvis
from what happened to him
uh which is funny because what happened
to him has been kind of turned into
these legends you know i mean about him
going crazy and pulling guns on people
and shooting televisions and doing weird
stuff like that
if you'd given that bit of b if you t
boosted that [ __ ] you felt a lot
better and none of that none of that
other stuff would have happened he was
just going through andrenopos
which like i said that's kind of sad
yeah it's kind of sad he didn't know
though
you go to the restaurant i mean that's
kind of the thing though i kind of feel
like there's this whole and
it might be partially cultural too yeah
um and this might be
you know not as prevalent nowadays but
back in the old days
a dude was meant to be like you were
meant to be like the breadwinner yeah
you're meant to be like on top of it and
once you were
too old to do that anymore
and
you know you're retiring well we've
talked a lot about
people of that era of that generation
very short life cyclist once they
retired they died
yeah they died like within a pretty
short air even though they probably
right should have lived like a lot
longer you can live a long time if you
have if you understand biology and you
have access to the chemistry but i kind
of feel like a life extension dudes of
that era
they define themselves
by what they did their job and you and
once yeah
once they didn't have that anymore
all right then they aspire to control
felt like they didn't really have any
yeah which
yeah don't do that don't define yourself
by your job if you look at it for crazy
if you look at elvis's final
performances he was a young man
he wasn't that old no he was a young man
he was in his 40s he was overweight
christ
but he was he was still older than that
yeah he he was overweight but but it was
all andronopause
nowadays you got actors that are much
older than him that look [ __ ] jacked
and they're [ __ ] having a good time
are they natural no hell no they're all
on hrt because now you know now you know
how to extend life how to extend
how to keep metabolisms up and running
will you live forever no you won't live
forever but you but your quality of life
will be better until you die i mean at
least that's all it is
good
like i said at least like
make the life that you have like as good
as it possibly can be and i kind of feel
like they didn't really
until recently they didn't really like
do that
and that kind of makes me sad
that kind of makes you sad
tammy says
albus and jfk
had to kill bobo jeffy that's not music
i love that movie you guys
if you guys have not seen boba hotel
please
watch it
uh that's what she's talking about
adriana says of course welsh people are
cool look at that dragon
yeah
um
like i said i don't know if you guys
know for a long time for 15 years i was
married to a welsh person
and i used to go back and forth to the
uk usually wales uh for a long time back
in the 90s
so i've been to wales a lot of times
and
yeah i i get it and and i get
they're very very proud of everybody
that comes out of
wales
tom jones
catherine zeta-jones jones very common
name over there by the way
and everybody that comes out of wales is
like super if they get like worldwide
famous everybody is like super into it
all right so
let's see what we got
tammy says
just put those old people on an iceberg
and send them out
yeah i know all right so i'm gonna go
ahead and
come back and answer tila's questions
directly yes
elvis or tom jones
if you're a man
and it's about music and entertainment
and musical culture
i'm gonna say elvis
if you're a woman
about sexuality and get to getting a
[ __ ] dick
tom jones tom's job i like
i think tom jones would probably put it
on you better i don't know if i could
pick he could sing too but i would
probably say tom johnson okay like
alexis [ __ ]
elvis and his heyday he was handsome
very very obvious haiti was hotter
but
jones was wrong
sexuality he had some [ __ ] going on in
star level sexuality just coming at you
who do i want to sleep with right that's
all like dudes are worried about right
um who do i i probably jones would have
been more
aggressive probably well i'm picturing
him as more
come on here
he he'd have been me leaner meaner more
low down and dirty elvis would have been
i think more of the romantic pretty boy
you know i'm just taking okay so i'm
more into the elvis yeah probably
for everson probably more like that
i'll tell you what just but the thing
but you think that elvis had issues
though too
well yeah everyone does yeah everyone
does elvis evidently had a reputation of
once he hit a couple times he was
interesting you want to move on to a new
one
so how is that different
he wasn't that romantic you know i mean
that's what i'm saying i tell you
everybody
so like every other man
that's really not that different too
we talked about me and you've been been
together more than 10 years i know yeah
so isn't that funny how she kind of
[ __ ] just goes well i'm not talking
about you i'm just talking about dudes
in general yeah do you think
yeah tom has swag
elvis did too but elvis was a little
more
elvis kind of had a the vibe of a
[ __ ]
king
and he was a king in many ways
he kind of had this magnanimous kind of
like
well just watch that [ __ ] movie
alison nixon with all what's his name
[ __ ] to do the plate dixon what was
that guy's name
oh [ __ ] bird
it's still a great movie even though
even though that dude doesn't look like
elvis he does convince you that he looks
like elvis but he doesn't look like
elvis again um
and uh
it passed the smell test of people who
knew elvis and goes like yeah we were
there that it was like that
[ __ ] uh what was that guy's name who
played michael shannon michael shannon
yeah he doesn't look like elvis but he
did a great job of us
i love michael shane yeah yeah he did
great he's good in everything yeah
he's like
he's one of those actors that like every
time you see him in a movie i don't know
tammy says don't pick just sleep with
both
yeah i mean that's the way to like
resolve the situation
yeah
yeah tina's talking about [ __ ] uh
just look at tom with all his duets with
women on his shows he loved all kinds of
women i prefer people like that yeah
well well
uh by all accounts tom was uh he was the
man you know
uh wales holds him up as a [ __ ]
national treasure what did he do i am
not gonna [ __ ] i've been there i've
seen it i'm not gonna [ __ ] say
anything against them like yeah i've
been there i've seen it he was a man
and they loved tom jones over there and
that was and tom jones at his height was
you know back in the day 60s you know i
mean we just did mars attacks yeah tom
jones was in that and he was around for
a long time
uh he was you know you're talking about
guys
from you know around [ __ ] sinatra and
you know [ __ ] old crooners from that
time you know what i mean he was one of
that crowd so
yeah [ __ ] right
him and sammy davis davis junior and
[ __ ]
but the thing about tom jones what's so
funny about sammy davis sammy physically
you look at him
and he's totally opposite of all those
other [ __ ] but he's like
holding his own he's this little black
dude
a little skinny black dude but no he
[ __ ] that [ __ ] results that's
exactly what i'm saying yeah
[ __ ] was also [ __ ] about the
whole physical thing it's not really any
spirit more anything else it's really
not that important yeah when you come
down to it he didn't really fit in with
his
with his competition but he held his own
with him yeah [ __ ]
yeah find a persona it was his
personality and owned it yeah
they loved him
he's a good dude yeah he's a good dude
well i'll we'll get into it he knew how
to [ __ ]
charisma i was talking about earlier in
the show it's hard to it's hard to
actually quantify what charisma is
well it's different in every situation
that's what i'm saying yeah
speaking of sammy davis jr
one of the things that
uh if you guys have shutter
there's a show on there called cursed
films
and
they've done a season two
the first episode was on wizard of oz
which was very good
second
episode was on rosemary's baby which i
watched last night
now most of that episode was about
uh
the mason
murders
but they also kind of went into a little
bit of the whole satanic church kind of
[ __ ]
and they did mention
speaking of sammy davis jr
that he was into
the whole satanic thing and he was one
of the only
celebrities yeah that was willing to
come out and say hey yeah i'm satanist
yeah well in um in in [ __ ] smoking
the ban at two i think is when he shows
up which we haven't seen that one in a
while yeah we got to see smoke in the
bed too
he shows up in its priests robe
but if you look closely he's wearing a
head of baphomet
and evidently that head of baffman was
given to him by anton levate or at least
i mean back in the day baby authority
yeah he was not real uh he wasn't
secretive about like hey i'm church
satan all the way
but i think he he it was tongue-in-cheek
with him because i think yeah sure he
understood what anton was
anton knew it was symbolic for
being your own person and rebelling
against conventionality
yeah i'm not like real like i kind of
feel like an atheist i'm sure that's
what that's what yes sammy davis is
talking he's an atheist poking fun at
conventional people
uh that that
he was you know that
by natural selection and his choices
through life he has risen above
the [ __ ]
taylor says he was also a jew
yeah yeah yeah he was also he converted
to judaism he but you know people just
did whatever they did back then
they also they were also into mystical
stuff
you know
well that was the people of the time i
remember it and the cursed film show
goes kind of a lot of like the one about
rosemary's baby
um is a lot about like the manson
murders because obviously because from
polanski and like sharon take got
murdered and stuff so they go a lot into
that but they do kind of go into a
little bit of the church of satan kind
of stuff that was going on
and they talked about
uh sammy davis jr
and how
at the time
i mean
late sixties raised marriage baby came
out what 1968
yeah
so there was a lot of kind of like
questioning of
um
religion in general like or at least
religion as it had been presented
prior so everyone's kind of like
i mean i know it's based on novel and
it's ira levin's novel which if you
haven't read that you should because
it's really really good but
was kind of like part of the whole
zeitgeist everyone in the late 60s was
questioning
all the religious kind of [ __ ] uh you
know [ __ ] that was going on conventional
[ __ ] wasn't cool right truth had to lie
somewhere else so everyone was
especially in the california scene which
i grew up there too
the california scene especially my
parents and my aunts generation
you didn't want to be regular
you wanted to be something different
so that's that was the direction that
they went
and it was all uh
it was [ __ ] really when you think
about it by today's standards you think
was [ __ ] but they were just looking
for a new type of truth
and then you're also dealing with actors
okay
pretty much all the actors of that era
were putting on a show it was their job
to entertain you
and if you really watch them especially
when you watch them on on [ __ ] on
talk shows
you can tell there's an there's an air
they're putting on there's an air of
[ __ ]
i don't want to say falsehood but
they're
they're putting on a persona oh
performance it's an air performance
right which that was their job
their job to do that
because show business is about illusion
and entertainment and you know what i
mean and
you're
trying to put on a good show for other
people and putting on a different face
and they even didn't even use their own
names it's show business they were all
doing it
so you can go back and look at sammy
davis and go but man he seems slightly
fake
well you go back to all the other ones
and you look at them they're all kind of
fake too
they're all fake
they were just yeah that was kind of
like part of their job sure that was
their job that was the whole thing yeah
right
it didn't really matter what color they
were i mean you know [ __ ] the white
ones were doing the same thing the black
ones are doing the same thing
um they all had fake names you know what
fake backgrounds go back and look at old
eartha kit stuff she's very kind of
artificial she's putting on a show
but they were all doing that
they were all doing that
you couldn't be yourself
because who you were were boring
you were working inside this hollywood
system that was a factory
it's really all it was
the factory to make this [ __ ] imagery
nowadays you take imagery for granted
your your [ __ ] cell phone could take
imagery
back in those days
you need thousands and thousands of
dollars worth of these damn huge [ __ ]
machines to take into imagery
so you had to you had a whole factory of
people trying to put on this show you
know what i mean to sell it to [ __ ]
multitudes through just a few channels
so
none of them were really uh
natural
they were all kind of artificial
products
and the studios knew that they'd replace
them all the time too
but i think that might be
one of the reasons that everybody
nowadays responds a lot better to social
media
yeah
youtube channels tick tocks stuff like
that like people just doing real [ __ ]
because
it seems a lot more honest than
constructed reality right that we saw
from like back in the old days right
so but there was i do respect those
people because there was a certain art
that they were they were before that's
what i'm saying yeah it's like you can't
[ __ ] on that because it's like look they
knew the game and it's like they
they
did that their job was to fabricate an
illusion to get you to feel a certain
way and that's what their job was they
want their job was to make you feel good
about yourself
that's a difficult job
if that didn't happen then the product
wouldn't sell they'd fire you
true yeah
but we're now in an area of social media
where all those controls are gone
all those [ __ ] gatekeepers are gone
the blockade's gone
a creator can speak to you directly and
be honest about it
it doesn't matter because you're going
to get the views you're going to get
you know the people that like this
interesting because you never really
know
what's going to resonate with people and
what's not
you know what i mean dumb [ __ ] still
seems to resonate cat videos resonates
was they are cute but cat
is resonate i also like cat videos
i put up our own but like i get it yeah
i watch other cat videos awesome like
that is also cute and i like try i try
to get pookie to watch them with it
she's like that
yeah yeah she's like that is another cat
that you're looking at
yeah somebody said that when you watch
old marlon brando videos you get the
impression you didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah and you know what that's kind of
what i think made him a legend he was
closer to what you see in social media
now
he's he's on set
he's
performing he's doing what they told him
to do
but he kind of doesn't give a [ __ ]
which gave him
gave him the air
of realism
which made the audiences connect with
him more
and that's why he's the legend he was
because that [ __ ] was crazy
marlon brandon was crazy he was always
crazy uh yeah you'd be talking to marlon
brando and all of a sudden you're you're
a man talking to marlon brando and he
just come and kiss you right on the
mouth and he said i love you
and you and what are you going to say
this morning [ __ ] brandon you go i
love you too
that's not everything you're going to
say that's what you're going to say if
marlon brando kisses you on the
[ __ ] mouth in front of a damn
camera and says i love you you're just
gonna say i love you too but i love you
too marlon
he was crazy he was [ __ ] crazy
he wasn't a bad man though he was just
crazy
you know
well i kind of feel like a lot of the
best creative people were yeah
you kind of have to be sort of crazy
yeah a little bit a little bit
but try to do that [ __ ] on a podcast you
get punched it was like i said it
doesn't work the same it doesn't work
the same way the context is the context
is not the same context
that's what we're saying yeah time is
not the same context right
and that's like a big
uh
kind of
that's a whole like [ __ ] thing about
that
you know
it's a cool [ __ ] thing about
should we sleep soon yeah you want to go
shut it off
i can always uh get something to eat
hungry yeah i'm starving okay
yeah marlon brando kissed richard pryor
that's right i remember that yeah
yeah he did that to a lot of people
if you were too close to marlon brandon
he'd kiss you right on your
[ __ ] mouth
that sounds like some [ __ ] that you
would do
well brandon was truck a lot of times
and well so are you but that sounds like
yeah and hey
crazy ants are you yeah and crazy and he
made a lot of money off doing very
little
that was another thing about marlon
brown it'd be great to just sit around
make a [ __ ] ton of money and not do the
whole house
well if you want me to come out here and
do this movie i need two million dollars
you know i'm marlon [ __ ] brando
you know what i mean he'd get it
it's like excuse me i'm just gonna eat
this doughnut and a way for a hundred
percent right yeah [ __ ] is
fantastic
you know hold on i'm marlon brando okay
right now yes yes my son
yeah what what do you want now his
greatest role last role was [ __ ]
superman if you ask me but looking you
know just saying
i mean can we watch that one foul kilmer
that had like all the animals in it yeah
i liked that movie a lot of people
didn't like it but he that same director
redid [ __ ] color from out of from
space
yeah i know yeah i like that movie
it had a little [ __ ] we should do
like a review of that one of these days
what's her name
in it playing the cat girl
one from [ __ ] the craft
for roosevelt
she played the [ __ ] half cat girl
jenny and i were doing a [ __ ] book
signing deal
over here [ __ ]
what'd you call it i was getting a
coffee
and one of the horror horror
was standing right behind me i didn't
even know
yeah and he said oh she was right behind
you you know this is not i didn't know
yeah should have said something i
recognized her immediately yeah she
doesn't really listen like all that she
doesn't look the same i thought she she
looked she i thought she was she uh she
looks very skinny compared to where they
are yeah but her face still looked the
same just really no i didn't i
recognized her almost immediately yeah
and i started from like far away i was
like oh my god it's like fur is a bug
and i know it was her and i'd be like
what's up furusa you looking good baby
cause [ __ ] i was talking to the girl
from
from [ __ ] um
i'm gonna call i called her a girl she's
older than me
the one from um
uh
with those blue eyes those crazy blue
eyes yeah what was her name
i got a picture of me and her together i
know
she was the one that she was in [ __ ]
um masters of the universe
and she was in um
the name of that movie
she's a masters of the universe and she
was in
one with the cenobites
yeah i know what was was the name that
movie
i remember in a second yeah this you
guys know what i'm talking about
let's see if they're saying
no but nobody's managed to do it tila
says tom and jenny yeah go to the movies
right this weekend before go see the
batman and go see x the batman or both
the batman is now in like the little
piss at theaters it's not even in
the main i don't want to see a [ __ ] in
dolby but they're not even playing it in
dolby anymore well you should have gone
earlier that's just going to be on
television
but it's supposed to be pretty good
looking pretty good i've heard i've
heard mixed things about it
okay go ahead we'll go ahead and shut it
down jenny
you think yeah if you want to
you hungry
uh yeah what do you want me to make for
you
well i don't know what what's down there
all kinds of stuff
i don't know you got like some ramen
type situation i can do that
what do you want you want uh a japanese
no okay but some other kind of like
ramen ramen ramen okay
i can do that pork
uh out of pork
okay well eggs are fine okay go ahead
shut it down
thank you i will do that all right don't
take off right all right
yeah i said piss aunt
all right
so it's been a lovely friday night thank
you all for don't you sit your ass down
no i'm getting ready to leave if i don't
get up you won't ever shut the show down
that is not true okay all right
see tila's laughing
thank you everybody for dropping bye
thank you everybody for a super chats
don't you go i'm not going anywhere okay
and stop it
we'll be back on it's friday right yeah
we'll be back on sunday afternoon thanks
for doing a movie retrospective yeah
thank you for joining by all right it's
been lovely
all right spending our friday night with
you yeah we will see you on
sunday
evening y'all fun you funny too too
see